da bin ich ja es gibt jetzt rasch allerdings wirkt es ein bisschen übers knie gebrochen ich
habe vorhin schon zwei runden gespielt ja werdet ihr aber gleich sehen wo die legacy features auch
gefickte scoreboards natürlich nicht natürlich nicht keine battlefield 20 42 musik ja weil das
spiel ja auch so viel musik hat so kurz was trinken naja falls jemand am start ist gucken
ob der captain poggers oder irgendwer noch ankommt ansonsten machen wir irgendwie ins
quad weil das game macht tatsächlich ist am erträglichsten wenn man finde ich zumindest
mit leuten zusammenspielt was kauer range was für ein ding
prime sap danke für den sap auch wenn ich nicht weiß was ausspricht so ranger ach jetzt verstehe
ich alles klar massive exquisite name so es gibt angeblich neue skins über die sich alle aufregen
die muss ich mir gleich mal angucken wenn ich in game bin gibt es irgendwie die möglichkeit limit
hat das ein setting dafür kein cap fps menü fps zu capen wer tatsächlich gut weil im menü
leckt es moritz willst mitspielen nee du musst bestimmt veterans gestellts machen oder
wollte ich jetzt falls du installiert hast
das wollte ich denn jetzt gerade sagen ach ja menü fps
natürlich äußerst bock weil ich kann das spiel jetzt noch nicht mal starten weil es im menü so
viel so viel leistung zieht wenn ich noch was anderes zeigen will das ist richtig hängen
geblieben zumindest ich zeige euch mal die patch notes und was ich auch witzig fand ist das hier
also im prinzip das was ich auch schon gesagt habe wenn wir uns dem stats übrigens soll ich
euch mal das highlight erzählen ich sage jetzt mal in anführungsstrichen da ist natürlich nicht
irgendwie eine aus schweden direkt sondern ich habe jetzt mal die patchnotes und die patchnotes
die agentur mit der ich ich muss vielleicht mal die sound ein bisschen leiser machen so glaub so
ist gut also die die agentur mit der ich die battlefield 20 42 sponsors gemacht habe also
die quasi so nennen wir es nennen wir dice vertreten hat zu mir gegenüber was ja nicht
wirklich stimmt aber ihr wisst was ich meine ja die hatten wohl den auftrag bei den content
creators nachzufragen von dice feedback zum spiel und ich habe das auch schon wieder gehört und ich
Die hatten wirklich die Nerven, mich zu fragen, ob wie ich Battlefield 42 finde und wie viel besser das jetzt mit den Patches geworden ist.
Und das fand ich schon irgendwie lustig, weil, also nicht so, als hätte ich da nicht eh schon zig Videos drüber gemacht oder so.
Zumindest, ich hab langsam echt das Gefühl, die haben immer noch nicht ganz verarbeitet, dass ihr Games suckt.
Ich glaube wirklich, dass die teilweise noch denken, ihr Game ist geil.
Zumindest, ich hab halt einfach geschrieben, ich gehe eh davon aus, dass sie nie wieder was mit mir machen wollen.
Und ich sag ihnen jetzt halt einfach mal, wie es ist.
Und da hab ich halt mal geschrieben, was Sache ist.
Ja gut, dass die nichts mehr mit mir machen wollen, kann ich mir vorstellen.
Mit der Agentur würde ich gerne was machen, die waren nett, die haben das alles gut gehandelt.
Soll ich euch vorlesen, was ich geschrieben hab?
Ich kann euch vorlesen, was ich geschrieben hab.
Also jetzt mal Namen und so außen vorgelassen.
Ich lese euch mal vor, was ich geschrieben hab.
Ich hab nicht wirklich großartig geflammt, ich hab halt einfach gesagt, wie es ist.
Mit dem Game.
Feedback Battlefield 2042.
Ich hab hier Moin.
Dann der Name von meinem Ansprechpartner.
Also die ursprüngliche Anfrage war ja.
Also es geht darum, wie sich das schließt.
Wie sich das Spiel entwickelt hat.
Was euch in welchem Stadium des Games gut gefallen hat.
So nach Patches, vor Patches, vor Release.
Nach dem ersten Patch.
Launch, Early Access.
Und was nicht gut war.
Und so zum Thema Spielerlebnis, Langzeit, Motivation, Server, Modi.
Ja, genau.
Ja, ich hätte einfach mal wieder.
Zumindest hab ich geschrieben.
Moin.
Gut, dann werde ich mal.
Latex drehen über Battlefield 2042.
Ich gehe eh davon aus, dass Dice mich nach meinen Videos als Creator nicht.
Wenn man irgendwas dabei haben will.
Gehe ich jetzt tatsächlich auch davon aus.
Alles andere würde mich wundern.
Ich hab das Game so hart geflammt.
Aber die soll eigentlich, ganz im Ernst.
Eigentlich ist es bescheuert.
Kritik sorgt ja eigentlich dafür, dass es besser wird.
Aber das will ja heute keiner hören.
So.
Also da hab ich geschrieben.
Erster Punkt.
Dank dem Trailer war man richtig gehypt und hat ein Battlefield erwartet, das sich auch wie ein Battlefield anfühlt.
Zweiter Punkt.
Maps zu groß ohne Details.
Siege of Shanghai sah vor Jahren besser aus und hatte mehr Details als heute 2021 Kaleidoskop.
Größe und 128 Spieler zählen für mich nicht als Ausrede.
Dann lieber kleinere und feinere Maps und weniger Spieler, wenn man das nicht hinbekommt.
Ingenieur.
In Conquest läuft man ewig.
Nächster Punkt.
Ohne dass was passiert.
Und wenn was passiert, dann ist es direkt Clusterfuck.
128 Spieler.
Vor allem Breakthrough auf offenen Maps.
Sind einfach nur eine Linie.
64 vs 64.
Vor allem auf Breakaway.
Unspielbar.
Für einen Gegner, den du siehst, sehen dich 15.
Und gegen Kaleidoskop.
Erste Base.
Breakthrough im Haus.
Unten ist Metro 64.
Mann, Kindergeburtstag.
Nächster Punkt.
Viel zu wenig Content.
Zum Start.
Zwei Spielmodi in All Out Warfare.
Wo einer nicht mal ordentlich spielbar ist.
Kaum Waffen, kaum Gadgets, kaum Fahrzeuge, kaum Attachments.
Obwohl man keine Kampagne hat.
Mega viele Entwickler hatte.
Und andere Games dafür liegen lassen hat.
Warum ist XP im Portal eigentlich immer noch nicht aktiviert?
Dass es Booster-Server geben wird, war mir direkt nach der Ankündigung klar.
Ja, es gibt Rush.
So, nächste Frage.
Wo ist das Scoreboard?
Warum gibt es keinen ordentlichen Server-Browser oder wenigstens Map-Selection oder einen All-Chat?
Warum sind das Legacy-Features laut DICE?
Nächster Punkt.
Battlefield 3 und Bad Company 2 spielen sich im Portal nicht wie Bad Company 2 oder Battlefield 3.
Objectives auf Häusern WTF.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, ob das nochmal in einem Patch besser wird.
Nächster Punkt.
Cutscenes und Force-Spawns am Anfang der Runde.
Dazu kommen Menüs, die kaum bedienbar sind.
Man kann Gegner nicht orten via Sound.
Allgemein war Sound immer absolut bombastisch in fast allen Battlefields.
In Battlefield 2042 nicht.
Das Game hat nicht mal einen wirklichen Soundtrack.
Hazard Zone begeistert 2-3 Runden, danach hört es keiner mehr an.
Ich mag Specialists an sich.
Aber es ist halt wie vieles undurchdacht und nicht zu Ende durchdacht.
Zum Beispiel Maria Falk als Sniper mit Selfie und Ammo-Box und Motion.
Portal ist ziemlich gut mit dem Rules-Editor.
Wenn man da noch mehr Features und Content einbaut, kann ich mir vorstellen, kann man damit echt was Gutes bauen.
Nächster Punkt.
Langzeit-Motivation nicht vorhanden.
Sieht man auch am Trend der Spielerzahlen auf Steam.
Zwei Drittel sind schon weg.
Das musste ich Ihnen nochmal unter die Nase reiben.
Der Trend wird auf Origin und Konsole ähnlich sein.
Apokalyptische Background-Story passt nicht mit Umsetzung Ingame zusammen.
So, das waren erstmal so meine Punkte.
Dann habe ich geschrieben, ich finde die Steam-Review- und Metakritik-Bewertung zwar etwas überzogen,
aber es geht in die Richtung, wie ich es auch einordnen würde.
Es ist eigentlich so viel, dass mir das jetzt alles gar nicht aus dem Kopf einfällt.
Von Bugs wie Hit-Track rede ich gar nicht.
Die sind durch die Patches etwas besser geworden.
Aber das Spiel hat im Kern so viele undurchdachte Entscheidungen,
dass ich schwarz sehe, ob da jemals was passiert.
Und ich glaube, dass da alles Gutes bei rauskommt.
Allerdings ist mir mal wieder eine Sache bei den Events aufgefallen und ich sage das jetzt einfach mal so offen, wie es ist.
90% der Creators sind einfach nur krasse Schleimer, die alles feiern, was man ihnen vorsetzt.
Das ist sicherlich für vieles gut.
Wenn man einfach nur Hype aufbauen will und Werbung machen, ist das sicher toll.
Aber ich hoffe nicht, dass man sich in der Entwicklung auf die Einschätzung dieser Leute fühlt.
Weil dann wundert mich gar nichts mehr.
Das Spiel ist einfach nicht fertig und hat an vielen Stellen gute Ansätze,
aber fast nirgendwo zu ende gedacht.
Hat natürlich nichts mit dir zu tun,
Ich würde mich freuen, wenn wir in Zukunft bei anderen Sachen wieder zusammenarbeiten könnten.
Gruß Max
Das war mein Feedback an DICE zu BF2042
also
Wenn die sich danach immer noch einreden, sie haben ein geiles Game gemacht, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
E surreal 6x3 Frustration
Ich finde es ja witzig, dass die überhaupt Feedback einsammeln.
Ich meine, die müssen einfach Reddit lesen.
The fuck, was anderes schreibe ich doch auch nicht.
Ach ja, zum Wetter.
Zum Wetter habe ich ja gar nichts gesagt.
Ja, ja, quasi.
Für die Agentur.
Die haben mich gefragt, über diese Agentur,
die das Sponsoring vermittelt hat,
ob ich mein Feedback zum Game abgeben kann.
Ja, gut, wenn ihr das wirklich wollt,
dann mache ich das.
Das Feedback geht eh def null, ja.
Okay.
Okay, ich zeige euch jetzt mal die Patch.
Achso, nee, was ich euch zeigen wollte, ist folgendes hier.
Guckt mal hier.
Das ist im Prinzip das, was ich auch bei Steam Stats geschrieben habe.
Ihr müsst euch das mal anschauen.
Es ist einfach
zwei Drittel weg.
Sogar mehr als zwei Drittel.
Und da sagt ihr auch,
unser Oberleaker-Boy,
Playerbase has dropped 70%
since launch.
Und die Stonks
sind auch getroppt um 18%.
Das haben wir letztens im Stream schon gesehen.
Sowohl Spieler als auch Investoren
sind nicht happy mit diesem Spiel.
Ja, da ist was dran.
Was hältst du vom Halo Infinite Progression System?
Ein bisschen langsam an sich, finde ich.
Von den Unlocks her,
hat es halt wirklich coole Unlocks, halt viel Trash.
Macht es New World?
Ich weiß nicht, was dieses Jahr mit den Games ist.
Von New World bis Battlefield.
Von Cyberpunk,
ach, was es denn hier alles gab.
Wir gucken mal ganz schnell
in die Patches.
Patch Notes.
Notepads.
Das ist auch so ein Ding.
Wird das eigentlich irgendwo im Spiel
weiter thematisiert, außer dass ab und zu mal
eine Ansage kommt?
Und dann Webster um die Ecke kommen kann.
Ich bin einst auf den Mount Everest gestiegen.
Von dahin ging es immer nur bergab.
Und dann ist es vorbei mit Notepads
und die Welt geht unter.
Ach, du dachtest, es sind die New World Spielerzahlen.
Ja, die New World Spielerzahlen, wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Einfach nur, weil es Spaß macht.
Ja.
Einfach nur, weil ich es witzig finde.
Das ist so ein Absturz.
So ein Absturz.
Ich kann mich da...
Ich wusste es.
Es war so klar.
Es ist so im Arsch.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Fast eine Million.
Und wupp.
Ach ja, es gibt natürlich
auch die Leute,
die sagen, Max,
es ist doch normal, dass MMOs nach Release
was verlieren.
Natürlich.
Steam Stats Destiny 2.
Ich glaube, das ist nicht so aussagekräftig,
weil es zur Release ja gar nicht auf Steam war.
Naja.
Es geht auch downhill, würde ich mal sagen.
Das geht auch ziemlich bergab.
Carlo, danke für den Sub.
So, schauen wir mal kurz in den Patch rein.
Bevor wir uns in das Vergnügen werfen gleich.
Ich habe übrigens gelesen,
bei manchen Spielern funktioniert die Maus nicht.
Nicht mehr nach dem Update.
Ist jetzt kein Witz.
Die haben es geschafft,
eines der Kernelemente
in einem Spiel kaputt zu machen,
dass man nicht mehr auf Gegner schießen kann.
Die Maus soll angeblich nicht mehr gehen.
Aber wie gesagt, ich habe vorhin zwei Runden gespielt,
bei mir ging die Maus noch.
Und die Hit-Track ist auch nicht gefixt.
Ich habe vorhin wieder richtig schön durchgeschossen.
Maus-Steuerung ist Legacy.
Ach so, ja natürlich.
Jetzt verstehe ich das auch.
Also.
Battlefield 2042, Update 3.
No Pads.
Alles klar, damit meinen die uns.
Nimm doch die Pfeile, das erinnert mich daran,
wo ich ganz am Anfang, als ich angefangen habe,
Half-Life 1 zu spielen,
da wusste ich gar nicht, dass man strafed.
Mein Mikrofon knackst.
Ähm.
Wenn man Mikrofon knackst,
dann ist es nicht so, dass man Mikrofon knackst.
dann werde ich es mal kurz abmachen.
Und.
Hast du was bei deinem...
Ne?
Moment, hä?
Moment, Moment.
Test, Test, Test, Test, Test, Test, Test.
Ne, das hört sich okay an.
Ähm.
Leute, ich mache es mal kurz ab.
Ich mache das mal kurz ab und stöpsel es neu dran.
Das könnte hier dran liegen.
So.
Ich glaube, jetzt ist es besser.
Jetzt habe ich, jetzt habe ich das mal entwirrt.
Und die Verlängerung ordentlich hingestellt.
Danke für den Sub.
Ich weiß nicht, wer war es denn?
Möb.
Fuck.
Direct X Error.
Ja, das habe ich auch schon gelesen, dass ein paar haben.
Bei mir geht es zum...
Also, wichtigste Sache in diesem Update.
Lass mal kurz durch.
What's new?
Weekly Missions.
Übrigens.
Man könnte einfach so eine Liste machen.
Dann wäre es nicht so viel.
Wenn man das in...
Also, es ist ja nicht so viel, aber...
Also, Wichtiges.
Wenn man da eine Liste macht, ist man fünf Dingern durch.
Insgesamt haben die tatsächlich relativ viel gemacht.
Kleinigkeiten aber halt zum größten Teil.
Also.
Weekly Missions.
Ähm.
Ich meine, es gibt eh nichts zum Unlocken in dem Spiel.
Und jeder, der das regelmäßig gespielt hat, hat schon fast alles unlockt.
Also, keine Ahnung, wo das hin ist.
Warum es in Portal übrigens keine XP gibt, verstehe ich nicht.
Weil du kannst auch gegen Bots einfach alle Etappen...
Attachments und so anlocken.
Also, kein Schimmer.
Zumal man das ja auch ohne Probleme in Portal irgendwie beheben könnte.
Somit für jeden dritten Gegner oder so, wenn die Gegner schwächer sind.
Was auch immer.
Alter, was ist denn hier los?
Ja, Rush gucken wir uns dann gleich an.
So.
Also, es gibt drei verschiedene Missionen.
Ich muss ein bisschen was trinken.
Ich muss den Hals drücken.
Okay.
So, Missions.
Portal gibt es jetzt Rush.
Das ist eine offizielle Playlist.
Die kann man spielen.
Das ist eigentlich ganz nice.
Custom Portal.
Presets.
Juckt jetzt nicht weiter.
Man kann im Rules Editor ein bisschen mehr machen.
Das ist ganz gut, dass man sehen kann, was den Gegner gekillt hat.
Finde ich eigentlich ganz gut.
Ja, es ist eine offizielle Playlist über Portal.
Sieht man dann gleich.
So, Quality of Life.
Du wusstest aber auch schon seit Monaten.
Ja, ich weiß.
Vielleicht ist er doch irgendwie hier.
Irgendwas am Start.
So.
Also.
Improvements.
BenBit, dankeschön für den Sub.
So, Quality of Life Improvements.
Das Menü ist verbessert worden.
Man kann angeblich jetzt besser Freunde und Feinde erkennen.
Okay.
Es ist smoother die Transition between Menüs und Matchmaking.
Ja, wunderbar.
Emily Smile, eine Milliarde Euro.
Dankeschön.
Huge Subscriptions hier.
Pongers.
Massive.
Ich werde jetzt einfach mal meinen Subscriber-Sound machen, weil ich kann nichts anderes machen.
Ich habe keinen Sound für Bits to Bit Donations.
So.
Gameplay.
Sie haben über 150 kleinere Anpassungen an den Maps gemacht.
Und angeblich ist es jetzt auch Audio etwas klarer zu hören.
Müssen wir mal schauen.
So, und hier unten drunter gibt es detaillierte Patchnotes.
Das Wichtigste ist eigentlich, dass es jetzt Rush gibt.
Und den Rest werden wir sehen.
Ich starte das mal.
Ach so, Leute.
Falls ihr irgendjemand von euch im Origin habt, dann ist es am einfachsten.
Wenn ihr mitspielen wollt, sagt mal Bescheid.
Oder ich gucke einfach mal.
Wer ist denn hier online?
Der Serious Max ist am Start.
Den entweihten wir.
Also Captain Pongers ist auch da.
Ja, da weiß ich doch, wen ich jetzt schon gleich entweihten werde.
So, und ich wundere Leute, im Menü ruckelt es.
Im Menü ruckelt es, aber im Spiel ruckelt es dann nicht.
Ach ja, übrigens das Knacksen.
Meint ihr das Knacksen hier?
Das da?
Das ist, wenn ich mich mute.
Manchmal mute ich mich.
Weil ich euch nicht ins Ohr husten will oder so.
Guckt ihr gleich mal den Weihnachtsskin an.
Oh ja, stimmt.
So, nachdem es im Menü ruckelt, werde ich mal kurz was umstellen.
Game Capture an, Display Capture aus.
Und in der Hoffnung, es capturt jetzt auch Battlefield.
Nee, nicht Halo.
Battlefield sollst du capturen.
Okay.
Capture Battlefield, please.
Battlefield capturen.
Jawohl.
Weil so ruckelt es im Menü nicht.
Ach so, Lautstärke.
Ich glaube, so passt.
Alles klar.
Den Skin soll ich mir angucken.
Moment, Moment.
Wo sind die Skins überhaupt?
Hier, ne?
Store?
Nee.
Collection.
So, Boris hat einen Skin.
Wo ist Boris?
Boris hat einen neuen Skin, habe ich gesehen.
Nee.
Wo sieht man, wo sieht man überhaupt die neuen Skins?
Wo ist, wo ist der Boris-Skin?
Das ist nicht der Boris-Skin.
Der Comrade.
Boris, Boris.
Haben die den Boris-Skin deaktiviert?
Boris, Boris hat angeblich jetzt den Weihnachtsmann.
Weihnachtsmann-Skin.
Ich weiß aber nicht, ob das jetzt hier dabei ist.
Also angeblich gibt es...
Reddit, Battlefield, 20.
Die haben es nicht.
Die haben es entfernt.
Alter.
Da sieht man mal, was das für ein Kackladen ist.
Die sind so detached von ihrer Fanbase, Alter.
Das ist nicht normal.
Ja, guck hier.
So sah Boris aus.
Ge-Comrade.
Ge-Comrade-Weihnachtsmann-Boris.
Ähm.
Was ich nicht so genau verstanden habe.
Ich meine, der Skin ist jetzt nicht irgendwie...
So...
Wahnsinnig geil oder so.
Aber warum wurde der Skin denn jetzt so krass geschitzt, Dom?
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Ach, ihr seht meinen Screen nicht.
Lull.
Sack.
Hier.
Leute, so sieht Boris...
So gab es Boris.
Boris-Skin.
Warum da jetzt so geschitztormt wurde, verstehe ich nicht.
Ich finde den Skin jetzt nicht sonderlich hübsch.
Aber so den Ultraschitztorm.
Weiß nicht.
Hier, Ge-Comrade-Weihnachtsmann halt.
Ich meine, das ist ein bisschen billig, wenn man ehrlich ist.
Weißer Bart und einfach hier so ein rotes Ding drum.
Aber was willst du machen?
Hat nichts mit Battlefield zu tun.
Ja gut.
Ich glaube, das muss man sich...
Das muss man sich bei dem Spiel eh abschminken.
Wenn es danach geht, müsste man die Hälfte aus dem Spiel entfernen.
Also deswegen.
Das ist eindeutig...
Das ist ja das, was ich nicht...
Das ist ja das, was ich nicht verstehe.
Auf der einen Seite so krass apokalyptische Weltuntergangshintergrund-Story
und dann Cringe-Sprüche und sowas.
Aber ich finde es jetzt im Kontext, dass das Game halt eh schon hart cringet.
Gar nicht so schlimm.
Ach ja, und...
Es gibt einen übelsten Ge-Comrade-Skin.
Ge-Comrade-Skin.
Und dann gibt es...
Der andere ist sowas von Kokona, Leute.
Hell yeah.
Passt mal auf.
Hier.
Äh.
Hallo?
Moment.
Muss ich...
Muss ich den anderen skinnen.
Weil Webster kriegt auch einen Skin.
Webster kriegt nämlich einen Cowboy-Skin.
Freedom.
Freedom-Skin.
Portal Rush.
Doch in Portal Rush gibt es angeblich...
Exp...
Ansonsten gibt es da nicht so viel.
So, dann spielen wir doch ein paar Runden, würde ich sagen.
Machen wir kurz den Soundtrack aus.
Machen wir hier die Capture, Display Capture, nee, Game Capture an, Display Capture aus.
So, als Ruckels kurz Hauptmenü, zack, Rush.
Ach so.
Zack.
Mal gucken, ob das hier stimmt.
Ähm.
Maus-Tastatur.
Ja.
Hör mal auf.
Oh, hoffentlich hat sie sich jetzt gemerkt.
Orbital Rush.
Bam, bäbäbäbäm.
Gucken wir uns das mal an.
Jetzt bin ich, jetzt bin ich echt gespannt, was da, was dabei rauskommt.
Leute, 300 FPS, das droppt eh gleich auf 50, aber gut.
Ach, ich hab niemand eingeladen.
Zack, ich geh wieder raus.
Ich geh wieder raus.
Ich lad Captain Pogger Series Max und die...
Ja, ja.
Ich würd, ich würd gern raus.
Das wär nett, wenn das funktioniert.
Kann man in...
Kann man einladen?
Kann man einladen, wenn man ingame ist?
Ist...
Ist das durchdacht?
Na, das M-Complacement ist nicht so krass durchdacht.
Äh, Leute, ich kann nichts machen.
Ich kann nichts machen.
Exit?
Weiß jemand?
Quit?
Weiß jemand, wie man aus der Konsole hier rauskommt?
Deck W.
Ach, jetzt geht es.
Jetzt.
Alter, wie, das hat ja drei Stunden gedauert.
Okay, leave game.
Squat.
Social.
Kann ich euch jetzt in...
...inviten?
Den Series Max laden wir ein.
Den...
...Capt...
...Poggers laden wir ein.
Joint ihr jetzt...
Joint ihr jetzt mit automatisch mit rein?
Warum sendet das 50.000 mal Party-Invites gerade?
Error!
Probieren wir es nochmal aus.
Jetzt geht's.
So, joint ihr jetzt bei mir mit rein?
Ach ja, ihr joint bei mir mit rein.
Nice!
Okay, das scheint ja zu funktionieren.
Okay.
Dann, dann wollen wir mal, wollen wir mal rushen.
So.
Einfach mal ge...
Alter.
Geht schon mal gut los.
So, wir müssen jetzt gucken, ob alles flüssig ist, ob es irgendwie ruckelt oder sonst was.
Dann müssen wir gucken, ob der Captain Poggers reinkommt.
Ist der Captain Poggers drin?
Ne.
In, in Queue?
Eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs, sieben...
...sechzehn?
Sechzehn versus sechzehn?
Sollte es nicht eigentlich 32 32 sein?
Sei nach wenig FPS aus sehr gut, das ist ja in dem Spiel normal, dass es da nicht viel FPS gibt.
Moment, ich bin Boris.
Was zum Teufel, ich will nicht Boris sein.
Äh, Captain Poggers, ich kann dich wieder entweiten, falls es irgendwie Error, Error gibt.
Ich spray jetzt einfach...
MonkaS.
Okay, wir machen das jetzt einfach mal...
...sprü...
...mit gesprüht und gebetet.
In Queue?
So, schön.
Ne, du bist drinne.
Also, wenn du in Queue bist und es irgendwie...
...Fehler gibt, sag, sag Bescheid, dann entwrite ich dich wieder, oder ich geh raus, im Zweifelsfall.
Wenn du in Queue bist und es irgendwie...
...Fehler gibt, sag, sag Bescheid, dann entwhite ich dich wieder, oder ich geh raus, im Zweifelsfall.
By the way, einer der eben mit der Freund geschrieben hat, ich soll zum HNO Arzt gehen.
Wenn ich sag, hallo HNO Arzt, ich hab nen trockenen Hals, ich muss mich äh, ich muss husten, und...
...hab das Gefühl irgendwie, äh, ich muss mich hier raus, und da ist etwas im Hals, so dann sagt er hier, äh, sind sie privatversichert?
Und dann habe ich das Gefühl irgendwie, äh, ich muss mich hier raus, und da ist etwas im Hals oder sagt er hier, äh, sind sie privatversichert?
Sind sie privat versichert?
Dann sag ich, nee.
Dann sagt er dann zu mir,
ja, dann nehmen sie sich einfach mal ein bisschen frei.
Und dann...
Und er macht dann eh nichts.
Wenn du hingehst und sagst, ich bin privat versichert,
dann macht er erst mal 50.000 Untersuchungen,
dass du...
Alter, was ist hier oben los?
MonkaS!
Okay, ich muss aufhören zu sprühen.
Okay.
Orbital erinnert dich irgendwie an Erika Haber?
Ernsthaft jetzt?
Ich meine, sowohl vom Setting
als auch von der Vegetation
und so hat das nichts mit Erika Haber zu tun.
Ich überlege gerade, was dich...
Meinst du, dass...
Ah, du meinst das, wo man
nach der ersten Base runterläuft in die Stadt?
War das der Stream oder lag das extrem?
Chat, das müsst ihr mir sagen.
Lag das, wenn ich spiele?
Wenn es laggt, dann muss ich umstellen
auf Game Capture. Es laggt, oder?
Warte mal, ich guck mal.
Ja, angeblich.
Mega Bad?
Okay.
Dann müssen wir Game Capture machen.
Game Capture geht besser.
Wie ist der Server? Gar nicht.
Einfach die offizielle Rush-Queue.
Hi, es ist Juhi, dankeschön.
Social sind noch alle da?
Rush.
Oh, jetzt sollte es flüssig sein.
Gibt es schon Mods,
um die Cutscenes zu skippen?
Nee, leider nicht.
Was für eine Auflösung.
1.080p.
Also 1.120 mal 1.080.
Gibt es denn TDM?
Ja, TDM gibt es aber nur in Portal.
Nur in Portal.
Hat jemand irgendwie
super krasse Geheimtipps
gegen trockenen Hals und Schleim im Hals
und sowas irgendwie, was weiß ich,
Eukalyptus-Dampfbad oder sowas?
Dann mache ich das.
Weiß auch nicht.
Ihr habt recht, ich bin schon wirklich Monate am Husten.
Honig in heißer Milch.
Poggers.
Wasser trinke ich, sauf schon relativ viel.
Also, Wasser.
Alter, Webster, dicker Sack.
Penchelhonig, aha.
Sehr viel Sodbrennen.
Äh.
Nee.
Ab und zu mal,
wenn ich gar so viel gefuttert habe oder so.
Aber nee, an sich.
An sich habe ich eigentlich relativ
äh,
selten Sodbrennen.
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht,
wo ich hin soll.
Ich eier jetzt hier auf dem Dach rum
und kann eigentlich nichts machen.
Achtung, wir machen jetzt mal was.
Uah.
Na, uah, nicht runterfallen.
Zeit, ein Vollboost, ja.
Wachst du morgens auf und hustest viel?
Äh, ja.
Also, nee, husten nicht.
Husten nicht.
Ich hab, ich hab, ich hab immer ziemlich, äh,
muss mich immer ziemlich räuspern morgen,
so nach dem Motto hier, äh,
ich hab dann auch übelst Schleim im Hals.
Muss ich dann irgendwie erstmal eine halbe Stunde
ein bisschen mich räuspern, husten,
so dann ist wieder eigentlich alles in Ordnung.
Jetzt ist, was gibt das hier, wenn's fertig ist?
Chat, Chat, äh, Chat analysiert Gesundheitszustand.
So quasi jetzt hier, so Doc, äh, Remote,
Remote, äh,
Beratung.
Eine Stunde Review von Angry Joe.
Oh, nee.
Wo sind wir hier?
Wo sind wir?
Wo, wo haben wir hier geile, geile Gegners?
Hätte ein Zwerchfell,
ein Durchbruch sein können.
Wo, was hat mein Zwerchfell denn mit Schleim im Hals zu tun?
Okay, wait.
Die Maps sind richtig gut durchdacht.
Es ist einfach, es ist einfach mitten auf der Map jetzt hier Stopp.
Guck, mitten,
mitten auf der Map ist jetzt einfach mal Stopp.
Hier ist einfach mitten so eine, so eine rote,
einfach rote Linie.
Oh, oh.
Was?
Hä?
Was war denn das gerade?
Kann mir das irgendeiner schlüssig erklären, wo ich mich da gerade langgezogen habe?
3 Liter Mountain Dew.
Ach ja, stimmt.
Für MLG Scopes.
MLG legit.
Ah, oh, der Chat hier wieder richtig, richtig auf Zack.
Chat weiß, Chat weiß einfach Bescheid.
Vielleicht kommt das auch von der Corona-Impfung.
Man weiß ja nie.
Kann ich hier noch rüber?
Nee, oder? Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Das ist nicht die beste Waffe für die Range.
Zumal meine, Achtung.
Oh, oh.
Also, wenn ich mit der Waffe den Typ nicht kille,
dann mit keiner.
Mach ein Corona, das hab ich schon.
Ich hab kein Corona.
Bin ich auch ehrlich gesagt ganz froh, dass ich kein Corona hab.
So.
Wir stellen es uns jetzt mal kurz hier runter.
Okay.
Ah, da hinten ist er.
Nein.
Pass mal auf.
Wir wallbangen den jetzt.
Das geht mit der Waffe nicht.
Okay.
Wir können es ja mal ausprobieren.
Nein, nein.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Nein.
Ah.
Auf einmal, auf einmal steht 3 hinter einem.
Null.
Wird jemals wieder einer Corona-Bier kaufen?
Nein.
Weil Corona ist pleite gegangen während Corona.
Kein Witz.
Müsst ihr mal nachgucken.
Corona-Pilz oder was das war.
Oder wie, wie Corona, die Corona-Brauerei ist pleite.
Corona-Extra, keine Ahnung.
Hallo.
Ich möchte hier bitte switchen auf meine Motion-Sensors.
Oh, oh.
Da kommt aber einiges.
Da kam aber einiges um die Ecke.
Es gab doch mal den Witz, dass die sich umbenennen.
Von Corona-Brauerei in Ebola.
Brauerei.
Weil das aktuell nicht, äh, nicht so vorbelastet ist.
Also, ja, irgendwo habe ich schon diesen Gag gelesen.
Das ist natürlich wieder richtig krasser Boomer-Humor gewesen.
Alter, meine Güte.
Äh, könnt ihr mal jetzt verrecken?
Was gibt's Neues im Frankfurter Bahnhofsviertel?
Ich war seit jetzt zwei Wochen nicht mal im Frankfurter Bahnhofsviertel.
Okay, RIP.
Milch mit Honig.
Ich glaube, das ist keine schlechte Idee.
Das mache ich.
Chat.
Chat weiß Bescheid.
Wir wissen es doch.
Guck mal.
Im Prinzip rettet mich der Chat doch schon öfters.
Der Chat hat mir letztens auch wieder irgendwelche Links gepostet zu irgendwelchen Patch-Notes und sonst wie was.
Der Chat weiß einfach Bescheid.
Ich glaube, das ist, by the way, nicht die richtige Waffe für diesen Einsatzzweck hier gerade.
So, wir müssen mal einen Motion-Sensor da hinten hinhauen, dass wir irgendwie die Chance haben, das, äh, zu bashen.
Was?
Okay, die sind alle down.
Motion-Sensor dahinter.
Alles klar.
Wenn wir Glück haben, sehen wir auf der Map sogar was.
Aha.
By the way, Map nicht zoombar.
Hat man sich auch gedacht.
Legacy-Feature.
Braucht man nicht.
Wer braucht zoombare Maps?
Haben sie sich wahrscheinlich im Zoom-Call überlegt.
Haha.
Lull.
Pains-Champ.
So.
Muss jetzt hier um die Ecke.
Ich dachte, da ist was, aber da ist nix.
Das Game ist trash, oder?
Ha.
Chat.
Ich würde das Game wirklich gerne...
Gerne, gern haben, ja.
Easy.
Easy win.
Wer nutzt noch Zoom?
Weiß ich nicht.
Ich hab Zoom noch nie verwendet.
Aber wisst ihr, was lustig ist, was ich letztens, ähm, gehört hab in einem Video?
Ja, ist gut.
Was ich letztens in einem Video gehört hab, die Cringe-Sprüche müssen wir uns jetzt nicht angucken,
dass es, dass Zoom, dieser, dieses Zoom-App-Hersteller, ähm, dass die gar nicht an der Börse sind,
aber irgendeine Firma mit Zoom im Namen,
hat den übelsten, hatte den, den übelsten, äh, das übelste hoch, weil, weil die gedacht haben, das wäre Zoom-Video.
Also die, auch die Stonks-Leute sind nicht, sind nicht so die Cleversten.
Deine Info ist leider korrekt, ja.
Oh, Manifest, nice.
Nice.
Mal gucken.
Manifest hat, finde ich, das größte Potenzial, ähm, eine gute Rush-Map zu sein.
Ist das Game mit dem Update nun spielbar?
Im Prinzip ähnlich wie vorher.
Auch schon wieder Defender.
Die M-Comps sind mal richtig beschissen platziert, sagt der Captain Poggas.
Warte mal ab.
Warte mal ab auf, äh, Renewal.
Renewal hat die schlimmsten M-Comps, Leute.
Wartet ab.
Ich hoffe, wir spielen danach Renewal.
Da könnt ihr euch, da könnt ihr euch mal angucken.
Da könnt ihr euch mal die beste, be-
Serious Max ist gecrashed, kann das sein?
Ja.
Jetzt ist er wieder da.
Du bist nicht mitgejoint.
Was ist denn hier los?
Jo, joint, joint das, jetzt?
Oder nicht?
Ja.
Ja, ja, jetzt gehts, ok.
Ey, was der Patch gebracht hat.
Also jede Menge, jede Menge Minim-, Minimalverbesserung ähm, und angeblich 150 Änderungen auf allen
Mepps?
Kann man hier rüber?
Oh, nice.
Wobei ich da ehrlich sagen muss ...
... Neeeehhhh ja.
Ich kann es noch nicht beurteilen, weil ich kaum Breakthrough bzw. Kongress gespielt habe bisher.
Alter, die Schneiber-Dudes, Mann.
Habt ihr mitgekriegt, wie es einfach keinen Kill-Sound gab?
Es gab einfach keinen Kill-Sound, als der Typ mich weggeschneibert hat.
Du kommst hier nicht hoch, keine Chance.
Man kann ja auch nicht robben oder so.
Ich spawne rein, wir sind eh Defender, das macht ja nichts.
Ach ja, übrigens auch eine Sache, die mir direkt bei den M-Com-Platzierungen aufgefallen ist.
Die M-Coms sind jetzt so weit auseinander weg.
Du kannst also, wenn du am einen M-Com bist und am anderen M-Com geht die Post ab,
hast du eigentlich gar nicht die Chance, da großartig irgendwie was zu machen.
Weil die so weit auseinander sind, das ist ja echt spannend.
Wo geht hier eigentlich gerade was?
Ist hier was?
Sind die Barren?
Ah, ich hab legit keine Ahnung, wo die Gegner stelzen.
Komm, wir gucken mal auf die Map.
Die Gegner stelzen gerade Richtung A eher.
Ach, wir sind hier, okay.
Ah, wo ist denn hier was? Da hinten?
Hab ich da was gesehen?
Ich geh mal kurz hier runter.
Ach ne, hier geht's nicht durch.
Ja, ist ja, she baited.
Wow!
Gleich defusen hier.
Defuse Champ!
Ach, guck mal, es gibt noch nicht mal eine Progress-Anzeige, wie man defused.
Oder? Doch, hier oben, hier oben. Stimmt, doch.
Hier ist Webster halt richtig...
Oh, da oben ist der Schneiber, der Schneiber-Man.
Guck mal hier.
Ich hab übrigens Fallschirm gedrückt, der ist nicht aufgegangen.
Wo sind sie hier?
Wo ist es hier? Wo sind sie?
Irgendwo hier, also ich hör hier 50 Milliarden Schritte.
Ich weiß halt nicht, ob das Gegner sind oder Teammates.
Angeblich ist...
Ah, ne, okay, der ist down.
Alles klar.
Also hier mag ich halt Webster, das ist richtig schna...
Pepega-Aim.
Da haben wir das passende E-Mode für.
Bist du auf dem leeren Server?
Ne, ich bin hier, guck mal.
Ist eigentlich, eigentlich alles, alles voll.
Wow!
Ah, ne.
Da oben, hier.
Leute.
Wartet mal, wartet mal.
Mal gucken, ob das geht.
Mal gucken, ob ich irgendwie...
Jawoll, gib ihm, gib ihm.
Pippo-Fett.
Der muss abnehmen.
Okay, das war...
Das hat jetzt nichts gebracht.
Ich dachte, hier geht es irgendwie sinnvoll weiter.
Spoderman, ja.
Richtig, richtig, richtig gespodert.
Okay, das passiert anscheinend manchmal immer noch.
Achtung.
Weg.
Ich bräuchte ein bisschen Ammo.
Ammo wäre halt nice.
WTF.
Passt auf.
Ich gehe zum Arzt und es ist dann doch ein Zwerchfell-Durchbruch, wie es der Chat prediktet hat.
Und dann sage ich, Herr Doktor, ich wusste es schon.
Dann fragt er mich, woher.
Sag ich, Twitch-Chat.
Wow!
Twitch-Chat.
Und dann wird mein Arzt sagen, ah, selbstverständlich, Twitch-Chat weiß bei sowas ja immer Bescheid.
Twitch-Chat ist ja bekanntermaßen richtig Poggers für Diagnosen.
Der weiß Bescheid.
Und weil der ja auch bestimmt Twitch kennt.
Okay, ich muss mal kurz warten, bis mein...
...Grappling-Hook wieder da ist.
Grappling-Hook, please.
Äh, ne, ist alles da.
Da, hier.
Wo ist er?
Wo ist er, der Dude?
Kommst du her?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Frau Diverse Operator.
So nicht.
Aha.
Der will legen.
Legehände macht er.
Massive Legehände.
Ich sehe ihn schon da drauf zusprinten.
Ne.
Ich diffuse.
Ah, fuck.
Ich habe versucht, eh gedrückt zu halten und...
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Und dabei die Gegner abzuamen.
Das hat nicht so genau, nicht so gut funktioniert, wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe.
Es gibt kein Progress-Balken.
Dann sagt der Arzt, nimm diese Pillen und du fühlst dich Poggers.
Ja.
Captain Poggers, ich komme gleich rüber, sobald mein Grappling-Hook wieder da ist.
Und ich wieder...
Äh, oder auch nicht.
Jetzt, jetzt.
Easy, Rats.
Die kriegen uns nicht.
Wo ist denn der Dude?
Ist der da oben?
Der ist bestimmt da oben, hä?
Ja, da wollte ich nämlich auch hoch.
Nice.
Da wurde er geschreckt.
So muss das sein.
Wow, wow.
Habt ihr das gerade gesehen?
Das hat einfach mal komplett, komplett geleckt.
Manifest spielt sich tatsächlich ganz gut.
Manifest spielt sich Rush in der Tat.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Da sind sie.
In der Tat ganz brauchbar.
Muss ich, muss ich, muss ich echt, muss ich echt mal anerkennen.
So Container-Stells können sie.
Wo war der?
Ah, der ist down.
Okay.
Ey, wisst ihr, was ich übrigens auch in so jedem Shooter richtig, richtig big brain finde?
Wenn die einfach irgendwo random Explosiv-Fässer hinstellen.
Ey, mein Chat, das würdet ihr bestimmt auch machen.
Also stellt ihr mal vor, stellt ihr mal vor, ihr seid verantwortlich für Defense, für die, für die Defense, äh, für die Defense, äh, für die Defense, äh, für die Defense, äh, für die Defense, äh, für die Defense.
Stellung hier so in so einem Hafen.
Dann würdet ihr bestimmt auch sagen, Moment, das Erste, was wir machen müssen ist, lasst mal ein paar Explosiv-Fässer hinstellen.
Obviously.
Okay, die, oh, nice.
Okay, Diffusen können wir natürlich vergessen mit dem Pantsman daneben.
Ne, jetzt, jetzt.
Pantsman, auf.
Diffuse-Stells.
Diffusors.
Ah.
Okay.
Kann man ja probieren.
Ja.
Geh ruhig was vor, da kannst du nächstes Mal wieder mitmachen.
Übrigens, falls einer noch mitspielen will.
Oh, wir haben es.
Easy.
Easy win.
Ich, ich dachte, die haben gerade gelegt.
Sind wir, sind wir Top, Top Squad?
Paints Champ.
Maps sieht sehr Defender-Favorite aus, ja.
Viele, viele Maps sind äußerst unbalanced und die MCOMs auch sehr Paints Champ.
Ach ja, fünf Hipfire-Kills.
Ja, klar.
Das war das Wichtigste, was man hervorruft.
Was man hervorheben muss, ganz klar.
Rundenzeit 51, stand da wirklich 51 Minuten?
Habe ich jetzt gar nicht gesehen.
Wenn man übrigens Glück hat, sucht das danach gleich ein neues Match.
Boah, ganz Hipfire-Kills.
Ja, wie wir ja wissen, Hipfire-Kills sind ja prinzipiell das allerskilligste überhaupt.
Und überhaupt nicht.
Easy.
Ach, das ist Restzeit, okay.
Ich frage mich, wann das Legacy-Feature-Scoreboard kommt.
So, wen haben wir denn hier noch?
Auf wen kann ich den jetzt noch enden?
Lass mal kurz, lass mal schnell reingucken.
Irgendjemand da, den ich enden kann?
Wer mitspielen will?
Also, Chat, wie sieht es aus?
Irgendwelche krassen Battlefield-Owner bei euch am Start?
Zwei, also wir haben einen Squadplatz auf jeden Fall noch frei.
Und temporär zwei.
So, was haben wir hier denn jetzt?
Defender auf, was ist das jetzt?
Ist das Orbital?
Ah ja, Defender Orbital.
Okay, okay.
Webster-Stelz.
Wisst ihr, dass ich, ich muss das nochmal sagen, weil das sagen die Leute immer so, ich kann nur das Game haten oder so.
Ich finde die Operator-Geschichte immer noch nicht schlecht.
Und ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass das richtig gut hätte funktionieren können, wenn es, oh, da kommt was Fettes.
Das ist richtig, also es ist halt nicht richtig in das Spiel integriert.
Und nicht richtig durchdacht.
Aber ansonsten ist das wirklich cool.
Du kannst, du kannst Webster nehmen für, für Mobility-Stelz.
Du kannst zum Überbrücken Sundance nehmen.
Du kannst, wenn du einfach nur viel aushalten musst, Maria Falk nehmen.
Das ist schon richtig, richtig nice.
Und du musst hier in dem Spiel noch nicht mal die Gegner one-tricken.
Also die, die, die, die Operator, so, so.
Mercy-Main, by the way, one-tricken.
Nee, du könntest hier auch richtig gut wechseln.
Weil die haben jetzt ja auch nicht so die Wahnsinnstiefe oder so, ja.
Hallo, ich möchte dich retzen.
Ah, nice, wurde schon geretzt.
Oh, ThePantsman ist da.
Nee, das hat nicht funktioniert.
Hast du die MP9 mit AI gecrined?
Teils, teils.
Ich hab am Anfang ein bisschen AI-Kills gemacht, den Rest hab ich ingame an.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Ich bin am Zaun hängen geblieben, super.
Ähm, den, die...
Das, das Trommelmagazin hab ich aber unlockt mit ganz normalen Spielen dann.
Aber MP9 kannst du ja gar nicht spielen am Anfang mit 20 Schuss.
Du musst mindestens 3er...
Du musst mindestens dieses 30-Schuss-Magazin unlocken.
Ansonsten ist es ja komplett umsonst.
By the way, äh, Orbital finde ich, ist jetzt an der Stelle gar nicht so Defender-favorisiert,
aber ich glaub, wir sind einfach besser.
Ich wechsel mal rüber.
Mal gucken, ob da auf der anderen Seite was geht.
Wie viel Spiel an Rush?
Ich glaub, das ist 16 vs. 16.
Wobei ich mir einbilde, vorher wäre das 32-32 gewesen,
aber wahrscheinlich hab ich einfach nur nicht richtig geguckt.
Ach, hier geht's nicht weiter.
Okay.
Ja, wo soll ich...
Dann kann ich...
Dann kann man ja eigentlich nur an diesem, an diesem Berg abcampen hier.
Vielleicht sind die Server auch unterschiedlich,
weil das wirkte...
Das wirkte deutlich kontrollierbarer.
Als vorhin.
Ist das wirklich 16?
Ja.
Dann hab ich mich vielleicht vorhin verguckt.
Das sind dann wirklich 16 vs. 16.
Wobei ich sagen muss, 16 vs. 16 ist auch mit Abstand,
vielleicht noch 24 vs. 24,
das Beste für Rush.
Meiner Meinung nach.
Alter, wie ich den weggesprayt hab.
Der Semmel...
Ja, ihr könnt mitmachen.
Dann müssen wir bloß euren Origin-Namen schicken.
Dass ich euch enden kann.
Okay.
Ah, ein Motion-Sensor.
Also, wir haben ein permanentes Squad noch frei.
Ah, nice.
Man kann jetzt auch...
Okay, das finde ich gut.
Man kann jetzt auch im Aus retzen.
Das ging in anderen Battlefields, glaube nicht.
Konnte man...
Konnte man in Battlefield 3 und Battlefield 4 Leute wiederbeleben?
Im Off...
In der Off-Zone?
Ich glaube nicht.
Ich glaube, das ging nicht.
Ich glaube, das ist...
Wahrscheinlich ist das hier aber gar nicht gewollt,
sondern nur ein Bug.
Venbit hat geschickt.
Ja, Leute, ihr müsst das nochmal schicken.
Ich bin ja mit...
Mitten im Game.
Schickt es mir am besten nochmal nach der Runde.
Wir machen jetzt die Runde fertig.
Und dann...
machen wir gleich nach der Runde Invite noch welche.
Aber ich muss nachher, wenn der...
Wenn der Captain Poggas wiederkommt...
Also, wir haben nur einen permanenten Squad-Slot.
Okay, das wirkt jetzt hier wirklich sehr Defender-heavy.
Aber vorhin habe ich mega auf den Sack gekriegt auf Orbital.
Also, ich glaube, das ist gar nicht so Defender-heavy, wie man denkt.
Boah.
Oh.
Was war das?
Voll...
Voll veraimt, aber ihn trotzdem noch gekillt.
Dich würde die tatsächliche Entwicklungszeit von dem Game interessieren.
Mich auch.
Und ich glaube, dass die Entwicklungszeit so in zwei Phasen eingeteilt werden kann.
Das erste ist, wo man noch gedacht hat, man macht einen Warzone-Konkurrent.
Und dann hat man quasi festgestellt, oh fuck, wir machen da doch ein Battlefield raus.
Beziehungsweise Hazard Zone alleine trägt nicht oder was auch immer.
Und...
Dann war...
Das war die eigentliche Entwicklung.
Also, die eigentliche...
Die eigentliche Entwicklung war wahrscheinlich ein Jahr oder so.
Oder...
Ne, nicht ein Jahr.
War wahrscheinlich so zwei Jahre oder sowas.
Eineinhalb bis zwei Jahre.
Und davon am Ende der Teil dann auch noch das mit...
Ähm...
Mit der Entwicklung, wo man gedacht hat, man macht einen Warzone.
Das ist gerade ziemlich unfair.
1,5 Jahre für Portal.
Ja, so würde ich das ausschätzen.
1,5 Jahre.
Man hat angefangen quasi einen Warzone-Konkurrent zu programmieren.
Und dann hat man gesagt, wir machen doch ein Battlefield raus.
Deswegen wirkt auch der Battlefield-Aspekt so roh.
Und die Operator an sich ja doch relativ durchdacht.
Der Pantsman ist da hinten.
Was macht der hier?
Der soll mal da weg.
Der Pantsman.
Ich glaube, der ist down, oder?
Hehehe.
Oh, oh, oh.
Ich habe nachgeladen.
Das ist halt das Ding am Trommelmagazin.
Das dauert ewig.
War weg ist Rush für etwas.
Das kann ich schlecht sagen.
Bisher hatten wir sehr einseitige Runden.
Grappling-Hook nach unten.
Ja, das geht tatsächlich ziemlich gut.
Das habe ich in der Beta schon festgestellt, dass es manchmal wirklich...
Übrigens, passt mal auf.
Wenn ihr denkt, ihr bekommt Fallschaden, könnt ihr einfach Grappling-Hooken.
Und dann ist der Schallfaden, äh, der Fallschaden ist dann weg.
Also man muss sich einfach nur, wie das halt in echt auch so ist...
...einfach nur mit einem Grappling-Hook nach unten grappeln und alles ist gut.
Five Head, ja.
Riechstiger Five Head.
High IQ Play.
Ach, guck mal, da ist er.
Da, und jetzt gehe ich da mal rein.
Oh.
Hahaha.
Beste.
Der Typ musste noch nicht mal das Target wechseln.
Der Typ musste nicht mal das Target wechseln.
Der ist einfach auf dem Turm geblieben.
Dann bin ich eigentlich ein Bäm-Headshot, dann bin ich eigentlich ein Bäm-Headshot.
Oh, der Käpt'n Poggers ist schon wieder da.
Also, Leute, einen kann ich noch in Weiten fürs Quad.
Einer geht noch.
Wie, warum haben wir nur fünf von elf geplaced?
Wir haben die übelst gereckt.
Verstehe ich nicht.
Aber okay.
So, dann schauen wir mal.
Fatal, dich kann ich gerne in Weiten, wenn du am Start bist.
Ach, du bist einfach so gejoint.
Poggers, Poggers, Poggers.
So, das heißt, wir sind jetzt vier Stück.
Sehr gut.
Rush.
Geruscht wird jetzt.
Die Skins gerade waren hässlich.
Ja, es gibt eigentlich kaum schöne Skins.
Guck mal.
Ich muss sagen.
Ah, okay.
Zu spät.
Aber, oh, Breakaway wieder.
Bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm.
Ich muss sagen, ich merke in Rush wenigstens so ein bisschen eine Struktur in dem Game,
wo man halbwegs einschätzt.
Wo Gegner sind.
Das finde ich schon mal ziemlich gut.
Ansonsten, Maps sind halt immer noch nicht sonderlich geil.
Und das M-Complacement ist auch ziemlich,
wenn wir mal durchwachsen.
Guck mal, jetzt sind wir, jetzt sind wir Attacker.
Die, die hier gehen tatsächlich sogar noch.
By the way, wisst ihr, dass das Dice gemacht hat,
was ich gesagt habe in meinem Video?
Ich habe gesagt, man könnte richtig gut
16 vs. 16 und 32 vs. 32 Maps machen.
Aus unterschiedlichen Gebieten der 128-Man-Maps.
Weil es schnell und easy, billig Content bringt.
Und da hat sich Dice natürlich gedacht,
ah, wenn der Max das sagt, dann machen wir das.
Jetzt muss ich mal gucken, ob das jetzt auch wieder...
Das ist tatsächlich 16 vs. 16.
16 vs. 16, Leute, wisst ihr eigentlich, wie angenehm ich das finde?
Dass das endlich mal sich nicht so,
nicht so, oh, oh, nicht so mega Cluster-Fuck-mäßig spielt.
Ha, fuck, ich wollte ihn out.
Outmovel, ich dachte, ich heile mich
und gehe dann wieder hoch, bis er runterspringt.
Die stellen mich irgendwann ein.
Ja, ich glaube, das Letzte, wo ich arbeiten will,
ist in Schweden bei Dice.
Okay, nicht das Letzte.
Das Letzte nicht, aber eines der Letzten.
Ähm, das erste Mal hier im Stream,
ja, nice, dass du deinen Weg hergefunden hast.
Ich lasse mich spawnen, Leute.
Spawnen, aber ich kann einfach hier spawnen.
Zack.
Wo ist er?
Okay, ich retze euch, ich retze euch.
Ich hoffe, ich hoffe, ich komme da hin.
Also, eins muss man auch lassen,
das Headshot-Geräusch finde ich immer noch nice.
Warum spielst du ohne Visier?
Weil ich, der Chat hat es gut erkannt,
weil ich ein Ironside-Enjoyer bin.
Oh.
Hat nicht funktioniert.
Ein richtiger Ironside-Enjoyer bin ich.
Seems legit.
Ich weiß auch nicht, woran es liegt.
Ich spiele nicht in jedem Game zwangsläufig Ironsides,
aber ich muss ehrlich sagen,
ich finde es in diesem Game tatsächlich am angenehmsten.
Schwer zu sagen, warum.
Wollte eigentlich auf das Dach.
Oh, Mist, ich dachte, ich komme da runter, ohne mich hinzulegen.
Ja, das war dumm.
Battlefield 4 hatte auch nice Ironsides.
Ja, ich muss sagen, ich glaube,
ich habe in keinem Battlefield bisher großartig Ironsides gespielt,
aber in dem Game, weiß auch nicht, warum.
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum.
Ich weiß auch nicht, was es ist.
In dem Game muss ich sagen, Ironsides, Poggers.
Nice hat was Gutes gemacht, die Ironsides.
Ja, wisst ihr,
Fatal ist wieder raus, ist bei dir gecrashed.
Kannst einfach wieder reinjoinen.
Moment, Captain Poggers ist ja gar nicht drin.
Ich habe den Captain Poggers doch eben im Chat gesehen.
Wow.
Der ist komplett explodiert, der Kerl.
Gehen wir mal auf die andere Seite.
A.E.K., ja, die A.E.K. war richtig nice.
So, Flank, Flank, stell's.
Okay, das war's, das ist ziemlich dumm.
Hier komme ich jetzt nicht mehr richtig raus.
Leg's wie weg.
Da kommt gleich einer, Achtung, Leute, ich sag's euch.
Mensch, kann ich einfach sterben?
Nice.
Okay, für die Range
ist die Waffe auf jeden Fall nicht gedacht.
Gibt es jemand unter euch, Chat,
der den Unterschied erkennt am Fadenkreuz?
Was Single und was Burst ist?
Das ist das Burst-Fadenkreuz, das ist das Single-Fadenkreuz.
Ich erkenne es nicht am Fadenkreuz.
Also man hat jetzt hier unten rechts auch eine Anzeige,
das ist auch neu.
Ich habe mich mal switcht.
Bin auf die Pistole gemusst.
Ist Rush gut?
Also ich muss sagen,
die M-Comps sind nicht gut platziert
und die Maps-Icon sind immer noch nicht sonderlich gut.
Aber dadurch,
dass es eben kein totaler Cluster-Fuck ist,
finde ich das bisher tatsächlich am angenehmsten.
Lasst mich in Ruhe, Leute.
Ich bin Ironside-Enjoyer.
Alter,
Pepega-Aimed.
Richtig heftig Pepega-Aimed.
Habt ihr das gesehen?
So Pepega,
True Pepega-Aimen.
Und dass man immer diese Overlay hat auf der Map,
ist auch doof,
dass man da nichts sieht.
Ich glaube,
Ah!
Jagd die Corona-Impfung noch rein hier.
Eine Runde Booster.
So.
Da gehe ich jetzt nicht raus.
Das ist auch für Ironside-Enjoyer nichts hier.
Wackeln der Kamera.
Das kann man ausstellen
mit dem Wackeln der Kamera.
Ich bilde mir auch sogar ein.
Ich habe das ausgestellt,
dass die Kamera so krass wackelt.
Wir rollen drüber.
Nice.
Ja,
aber ich bin nicht so gut.
Ich bin nicht so gut.
Ich habe Breakaway noch nie gewonnen hier.
Also ich habe ja auch Breakaway
noch gar nicht als Attacker gespielt.
Wo geht hier was?
Motion-Sensor rein.
Alter!
Ach, das war der gar nicht.
Ich wollte gerade sagen,
der hat aber gut draufgezogen hier.
Wenn es der war,
den ich gesehen habe.
Aber das war der nicht.
By the way, hinlegen.
Alter! Tür!
Tür!
Geh auf, Mann!
Lege, Henne!
Habe ich es noch?
Oh, ich habe es noch.
Jetzt muss da einer reinpushen
und dann...
Oh, Südkorea ist am Start, Leute.
Ah, diffused.
Diffused.
Wie ging nochmal der Trick bei Hetzer,
damit man das ein bisschen günstiger bekommt
als die vorgefertigten Angebote?
Du musst meinen Code einlösen.
Ausrufzeichen Hetzer in Chat.
Du musst einfach mal
20 Euro Startguthabencode
einlösen. Easy.
Kannst du quasi einfache Server
drei Monate betreiben?
Was genau?
Hittet mich?
Oh, oh.
Das war eine dumme Idee, Leute.
Das war eine richtig dumme Idee.
Auch für Ironside-Enjoyer.
Nice.
Aber sind das alles Headshots?
Warum mache ich nur so viele Headshots?
Headshot-Enjoyer, würde ich sagen.
Das geht halt am besten mit Ironsides.
Nein, Schwachsinn.
Geht natürlich mit Red Dot und so.
Ganz genauso.
Charlie Mike.
Was für krasser Militär-Slang ist das?
Ich kenne Oscar Mike.
Das heißt On Move oder sowas.
Was ist denn Charlie Mike?
CM.
Keine Ahnung.
Schon den Weihnachtsmann-Skin freigeschaltet?
Nein, der wurde entfernt, wie es aussieht.
Wir wackeln einfach mal ein bisschen rum.
Pass mal auf, Trick 17.
Oh Mann.
Meine geilen
Grappling-Hook-Moves funktionieren nicht.
Continue Mission.
Alter, die Leute sind wieder so Six-Head hier im Chat.
Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Warum habe ich eigentlich so ein extrem
High-IQ-Game?
Bist du dir sicher, dass ich den gekillt habe?
Ich bin gestorben,
noch bevor ich den überhaupt richtig abschießen konnte.
Aber wenn das Spiel sagt,
ich habe den geheadshottet, dann habe ich den geheadshottet.
So, jetzt können wir uns hier richtig
nice hoch grappeln.
Äh.
So war das nicht gedacht, aber okay.
Oh.
Angel.
Angel did it again.
Ah.
Da kommt was von hinten.
Oh, nice.
Wir haben es.
Okay.
Ich habe ein bisschen Schiss, ehrlich.
Oh.
Freund-Feind-Erkennung ist einfach so genial in dem Game.
Du siehst immer sofort, wer Freund und Feind ist.
Ich glaube, ihr habt, das war euch auch absolut klar wieder gerade.
Kann das sein, dass wir die richtig heftig überrollen?
Hallo, mein Springen geht nicht.
Ich kann nicht mehr springen.
Mein, mein, mein,
mein Springbutton ist kaputt.
Einfach denied.
Ach, der Springbutton war kaputt,
weil ich in einer permanenten Springanimation
gelockt war.
Verstehe. Seems legit.
Kriegt man im Portal wieder XP,
ähm, also zumindest in der offiziellen
Playlist wie Rush, kriegst du noch XP.
Oder kriegst du,
kriegst du XP. Easy win.
Was soll ich sagen?
Kann dazu nur sagen, ich bin einst auf den Mount Everest gestiegen.
Seit da gingst du noch bergab?
Yes.
Everything as I expected.
Oh, diese Sprüche.
I told you to keep up.
That's it?
I'm ready for a run, too.
Ich frag mich immer noch, wer sich bei DICE gedacht hat,
dass das eine gute Idee ist.
Painz-Champ, aber richtiger Painz-Champ.
Damals warst du auch ein Abenteuer,
aber dann ein Pfeil ins Knie.
Ja gut, das ist ja schon...
Das kommt aus Zeiten, wo Leute noch auf YouTube
Fus-Rodar-Collections gemacht haben.
Das ist ja schon komplett
2014 oder so.
Oder noch früher.
Ach, dick, geht direkt weiter einfach.
Game vorbei, bam, nächstes.
So mag ich das.
Was macht eigentlich der Captain Poggers,
ist der wieder da?
Ist das Spiel jetzt spielbar?
Warte auf ein 30-Minuten-Video mit einem Up,
denn ja, 30 Minuten kann ich da nicht wirklich drüber machen.
Ich mach wahrscheinlich ein Video über Rush
und sag, dass ich den Eindruck habe,
dass es immer noch am wenigsten Clusterfuck hat
und ich deswegen Rush aktuell auch bevorzuge.
Ich muss echt sagen, Rush ist...
Du musst hier nicht permanent
ultra auf Zack sein.
Und wisst ihr, was lustig ist?
Dass so ein einfacher Modus wie Rush
und weniger Spieleranzahl
das Game einfach instant besser macht.
Wo man wieder sieht, dass
die Idee mit 128 Spieler
und dann auch irgendwie
Breakthrough und Conquest only
keine gute Idee war.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass hier auch wunderbar
Domination oder
schmaleres Conquest funktionieren würde.
By the way, Fallschaden geht weg,
wenn man hier...
Sprungstells macht.
Was vollkommen logisch ist.
Battlefield-Physics.
Bashen, Alter, bashen.
Bashen, Alter, bashen, Mann.
Motion-Sensors.
Toll.
Hier unter mir geht ordentlich was.
So stelle ich mir das mit dem Movement vor.
Und es ist auch richtig nice,
wenn du mal nicht von 50 Ecken
abge-aimt wirst.
Oh.
Okay, das hat er gut gemacht.
Neue Waffe, MP9.
Ist die auch OP?
Keine Ahnung, die war schon immer ziemlich gut.
PP-29, da sind wir gerade wieder dabei.
Moment, wie?
Wir müssen...
Nee, wir müssen attacken,
wir müssen nicht defenden, ne?
Ich habe mich gerade
schibäden lassen von der Ansage.
Am geilsten finde ich immer noch
den Ansager auf Kaleidoskop
Let's the base breakthrough.
Wenn er dann sagt,
ähm,
we are winning,
just take the objective.
Dann haben wir es.
Dann habt ihr mal Kaleidoskop
Breakthrough gespielt,
Let's the base.
Just take the objective,
Five head.
Nee, four head.
Just win.
Easy.
Just take the objective.
Gut, dass du es gesagt hast.
Wäre ich so überhaupt nicht drauf gekommen.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, nice.
Ich kann dich nicht retzen,
du bist in der Wand.
Das ist anscheinend immer noch drin,
als Bug.
Wenn man in der Wand steckt,
dann kann man nicht wieder,
wenn man in der Wand steckt,
dann kann man nicht wieder überlebt werden.
Zählen im Portal nun mit Rush
auch auf die Kills mit den Attachments?
Ja.
Wir können mal kurz switchen,
dass wir schneller da sind.
Ich finde es übrigens auch sehr nett,
dass sie uns spawnen auf dem Kran,
dass man mit seinen Specialists
auch ordentlich was machen kann.
Aber da sieht man,
Manifest ist tatsächlich auch als Rush-Map ganz okay.
Bisschen Defender-heavy, ja,
aber es ist wenigstens mal eine ordentliche Map.
Boah.
Da oben wird abgecampt, man.
Da habe ich jetzt nicht mit gerechnet.
Okay, wir gehen ja wieder als
Rappeling Hook-Stelzmann rein.
Oh, was ist das?
Warum habe ich da auf einmal Raketen?
Ich habe Raketen.
Das finde ich, das finde ich nice.
Bin mir zwar nicht so,
nicht so ganz sicher,
was ich damit machen soll.
Aber ich habe Raketen.
Und Raketen sind ja bekanntlich einfach...
...bekanntlich immer nice.
Wie schieben die da raus?
Wie schießt man mit diesen Dingern überhaupt?
Ne, da bin ich zu dumm für.
Ich kann nicht aussteigen, Leute.
Mein Aussteigetaste ist broken.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Ah, Gott.
Ah, ich bin aber lang...
Ich bin rangeslided.
Vielleicht mit Quick Revive.
Welche Grafikkarte?
Ich habe eine 1080 Ti.
Oh, Stelz-Action, Leute.
Ja, klar.
LMG legit, Mann.
Mit LMG.
Ich auch.
Wie ich auf 100 FPS komme.
Alles auf Low stellen.
Alles auf Low.
Leute, wir müssen jetzt gewinnen.
Only wins.
Oder auch nicht.
Komme ich da irgendwie rauf?
Leute, ich habe gedrückt.
Ich habe gedrückt.
Aber manchmal funktioniert das nicht.
Ach ja, und es ist 16 vs 16.
Just take the objective.
Easy.
Just win.
Wisst ihr was?
Das ist doch ganz einfach.
Doch alles easy.
Ich glaube, wir sollten einfach jetzt rüberflanken.
Sodass die uns gar nicht krass abstelzen können.
Hä?
Dass man jetzt...
Oh, fuck.
Jetzt ist er down.
Aber ihr könnt bei mir sponsern gleich.
Oh, wir haben nur noch 12er Tickets.
Fuck.
Na dann.
Dann war das wohl doch keine so schlaue Idee von mir jetzt.
Aber B ist auch ziemlich offen.
Haha.
Lol.
Oh nein.
Okay, wir haben noch 6 Tickets.
Komme ich hier rüber?
Ah.
Nice.
Okay.
Seriously.
Oh ne, da steht ein Pantsman daneben.
Fuck.
Der Pantsman ist am Start.
Wir machen jetzt.
Wir machen das jetzt, Leute.
Vergiss es.
Okay.
Dass die Defender einen Panzer haben, ist natürlich unglücklich.
Da machst du nix.
Captain Porgas ist wieder da jetzt.
4er Squad.
Easy Wins.
Nur noch Easy Wins ab jetzt.
Problem ist nur, wir haben keine Tickets mehr.
Also vielleicht doch...
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Okay, das war's.
GG.
Eats.
Maya, oh, danke für den Sub.
Ja.
Kali Rex sehe ich auch so.
128 einfach.
Haha.
Hahaha.
Diese Sprüche sind so schlimm.
Ja.
Also.
Wie gesagt, für einen Gegner, den du siehst, sehen dich 10.
Das ist blöd.
Und da sieht man wieder, wie viel besser sich das Ganze jetzt schon spielt.
Einfach mit weniger Spieler auf bisschen engerem Raum.
Und dann ist das schon viel angenehmer.
Leider ist wahrscheinlich Rush kein wirklicher, würde ich sagen, so...
Kern.
Gedanke von denen in dem Spiel.
Deswegen werden die wahrscheinlich am M-Complacement gar nicht so viel machen mehr in Zukunft.
Die sagen jetzt, hier habt ihr Rush und alles ist gut.
Doch, es gibt Helis in Rush.
Kommt auf die Maps an.
Es gibt Helis.
Ich glaube, hier auf Orbital hast du, glaube ich, ab der zweiten Base ein Heli.
Wart's mal ab.
Es gibt Helis, auch in Rush.
Aber gut, du hast jetzt nicht so dieses Ultra-Gestellte da mit 5 Helis, 5 Jets und sonst was.
Wie in Conquest.
Was ich persönlich als Infanterie-Spieler aber auch gut finde.
Ja, stimmt.
Auf, äh, Breakaway hatten wir auch eben...
Die... den Heli.
Ach, guck mal, das merkt sich jetzt ja sogar...
Ob man Burst-Modus hat oder nicht.
Sag mal...
Max, kann das sein, dass bei dir irgendwie immer beim Start der Runde das ein wenig rumbackt?
Wir gehen direkt auf B. Auf B sind meistens wenige Gegner.
Was?
Alter, ich hab den mit...
Mit der MP9 aus nächster Nähe reingerotzt, äh.
Ist absolut broken, okay.
Gut, der hat aber eine Armor-Plate gehabt.
Und ich konnte mich nicht bewegen, weil ich eh drücken musste.
Ich würde planten.
Planten und aimen auf Gegner ist eh so ein Ding für sich.
So, mal gucken, wie krass Defender-Heavy das ist.
Schauen wir mal.
Wir hauen jetzt erstmal da einen Motion-Sensor rüber und gucken, was da abgeht.
Okay, viel geht da.
Ab, viel.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja.
Guck mal, da drüben steht schon der Nächste.
Jetzt nächster Motion-Sensor rüber.
Alles klar.
Au!
Von wo, Mann?
Oh, nee, rechts.
Ah.
Wurde was an der Performance gemacht?
Ja, es sind jetzt 16 vs. 16 Spieler nur.
Krieg ich einen Rats?
Wär auf jeden Fall nice.
Leute, Big Brain Rats?
Ja.
Oh, nee.
Nee, okay.
Sie sind down.
Ist der Ramm League gefixt?
Nö.
Hast du immer noch?
Ja, ich kann nicht aussteigen.
Ist immer noch nice in Memory Leagues.
Jetzt.
Lege Henne.
Jawoll.
So, ich camp mir jetzt hier einen ab, Leute.
Massive Camp-Stelz.
Ich bin...
Ich mach hier wirklich...
Dem Ultra...
Wie hieß er?
Ah, ich hab vergessen.
Wie hieß mein Ultra-Stelzer-Video-Typ?
Das gibt's ja nicht.
Jetzt hab ich den Namen tatsächlich vergessen.
Black Ops 1 Havanna.
Wie hieß der Typ denn?
Ihr wisst doch, Chat.
Ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Der...
Der Ultra-Stelzer?
Nee.
Wie hab ich...
Der Ultra-Skiller.
Der Ultra-Skiller war das.
Ja, genau.
Nicht der Ultra-Stelzer, der Ultra-Skiller.
Wie, haben die diffused?
Was ist hier los?
Keg, wait.
Ach, nee.
Ah, haben sie noch.
Okay.
Ich hab das Gefühl, in Battlefield ist es so,
umso weniger M-Comps die Gegner haben,
umso schwerer wird's,
weil sich alles konzentriert
auf dem M-Com.
In dem Fall geht es aber,
weil es ja halt nur 16 vs. 16 ist.
Guck mal hier.
Pass auf, jetzt will er einen wegstelzen hier oben.
Guckt's euch an.
Nicht jetzt.
Wie sie rumschreit.
Die alte, äh...
Sag mal, können die mal please...
Können die mal please sterben?
Alle haben so Panzerplatten oder sonst was.
Da muss jetzt mal...
Guck mal.
Da muss jetzt mal richtig gebasht werden hier.
Beide Armor, ja.
Obwohl ich schon mit der MP9
die beste Nahkampf...
Also mit die beste Nahkampfwaffe hab.
Bin die K30?
Was sagt ihr, Leute?
MP9 oder K30?
Also quasi Vector oder MP9?
Nein.
Alter, ich check nix mehr hier.
Vector?
Ah!
Die hab ich noch gar nix freigespielt.
Oh, oh.
Nein!
Ich will dich retzen, Mann!
Okay.
Jetzt mal so ne Ammo-Kiste wär nice.
Captain Poggas, ich komm mit.
Auf geht's.
Oh.
Jetzt hätt man den Halo Master Chief Move machen können.
Ranziehen, ranziehen.
Und...
Voll in your face schl...
Meine Güte, ey.
Was geht denn hier ab?
Muss mich verpissen.
Okay, jetzt müssen wir ran.
Oh.
Von der Seite.
Also, ich muss sagen, ich fand das gar...
Also, ihr habt's ja gesehen.
Wir haben übelst dominated als Defender.
Und die geht's...
Ich hab vorher ne Runde gespielt offstream
und hab richtig auf den Sack gekriegt.
K30 Extended Drum.
Ich hab noch für die K...
Ich hab noch gar nix...
Gar nix...
Oh, oh.
Hier, da muss ich rein.
Da muss ich rein, rein hier.
Gib ihm.
Okay.
Handsman.
Oh, nee.
Das ist das Raketending.
Das Raketending ist ja richtig dumm.
Achtung.
Oh.
Nein, du sollst ja nicht hochklettern.
Alter.
Pepo, fett.
Oh.
Ich bin ein wenig exposed.
Nein.
K30 Extended Drum.
Okay.
Die Sache ist die...
Was eine dumme Waffe.
Ich kann jetzt keine...
Ich kann jetzt keine K30 freispielen,
weil das dauert ewig.
Da müsste ich...
Ich müsste jetzt...
Ich müsste jetzt eigentlich so eine 20 Minuten,
20, 30 Minuten Runde gegen Bots machen.
Dann hätte ich es freigespielt.
Wir müssen mal, weil das Spiel kein Soundtrack hat,
wie euch auffällt.
Das Spiel hat ja absolut keinen Soundtrack.
Machen wir mal ein bisschen was Gescheites an.
Was gefällt dir beim Patch bisher am besten?
Ja, dass Rush dabei ist.
Rush ist pock.
Also ganz ehrlich,
alles, was nicht 128 ist,
ist eigentlich pock.
Ich...
Ich muss sagen,
16, 16 ist okay.
Ich denke, 24, 24 hätte man auch machen können.
Oder aber...
Man hätte...
Man hätte die M-Comps besser platzieren müssen.
Hier sind nämlich die M-Comps teilweise relativ weit auseinander.
Gerade am Anfang.
Mir ist nicht mehr aufgefallen, dass keine Musik läuft.
32 Rush.
Ja, aber nur Custom.
Die offizielle Playlist scheint mir 16 vs. 16 zu sein.
Was ich aber auch gut finde,
weil es einfach mal kompletter Kontrast
zum üblichen Battlefield Clusterfuck ist.
Nachdem man in dem Spiel eh keine Schritte hat,
kann ich die Musik einfach anlassen.
Wobei, ne, ich mach die Musik aus.
Das mach ich...
Das, das, das, das...
Ich weiß nicht, ob euch das auffällt.
Irgendwie mach ich das öfters.
Ich bin da, bin da im...
Ich sag was schneller, als ich im Kopf denken kann,
weil ich hab das total oft festgestellt,
dass ich sag, ah, ich mach jetzt das
und ich sag dann quasi im gleichen Atemzug danach,
ach, ne, doch nicht.
So als hätt ich's überhaupt nicht richtig durchdacht.
Also hab ich ja auch nicht.
Obviously.
Nicht durchdacht.
Wenn ich Glück habe...
Haben wir nicht...
Uh, Poggers!
Der Captain Poggers ist am Start.
Bullish.
Alter.
Okay.
Hier voll im Kopf.
Ne, war gar nicht im Kopf.
Aber wenn wir Glück haben, können wir hier Grassen...
Nein, nein, nein, ich hänge fest.
Nicht jetzt, genau, so sieht's aus.
Nicht jetzt.
Fuck.
Jetzt haben doch zu viel geguckt.
Spielst du Borderless oder Fullscreen?
Ich spiele...
Was hab ich hier eingestellt? Gute Frage.
Ich hab Borderless, glaub ich, eingestellt.
Ja.
An sich ist...
Also, in jedem anderen Game außer Battlefield
wär ich mir da auch sicher, dass Fullscreen besser ist.
Theoretisch zumindest.
Praktisch spürbar.
Eigentlich selten.
Ne, der Unterschied zwischen richtigem Fullscreen
und Borderless ist halt,
Borderless läuft halt noch über den Windows Composite Manager.
Wie heißt das?
Windows.
Ähm, Windows-Dings, Windows-Fenster-Renderer.
Und Fullscreen macht das Game halt selbst.
Was theoretisch...
...picken schneller ist.
Alter, können die mal sterben, please, alle?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Alter!
Für das, dass es 16 vs. 16 ist, geht hier ganz schön gut was ab.
MN... Ne, DWM.
DWM heißt das, ja.
Was ist denn? DWM? Desktop-Window-Manager?
Oder, oder was ist, was ist das?
Oh, nice, hier.
Pogger-Spawn im Auto.
Sehr schön.
Äh.
Das hat ja gut funktioniert.
Oh, oh.
Da kommt gleich noch was.
Ja, okay, jetzt war aus.
Jetzt, jetzt war zu viel.
Jetzt waren die Schüsse aus.
Da sieht man aber in dem Spiel, du brauchst unbedingt viel Schuss.
Diese ganzen Waffen mit 20 Schuss oder so sind komplett...
äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh...
Schusslösung kannst du eigentlich gar nicht verwenden.
Also, ich, Chat, ich habe meine, meine Zweifel, dass das Game in einem Jahr keine Bugs mehr hat.
Das hat in einem Jahr...
wahrscheinlich andere Bugs.
Ich hab nen Pogger aus.
Nein!
In drei, nein, in drei Jahren ist das nächste Battlefield raus.
Guck mal, da liegen sie rum.
Und machen nix.
Oh, nice flank.
Massive six head flank.
Oh, nice flank. Massive six head flank.
Bester flank aller Zeiten.
Bester flank EU.
So, und jetzt gehen wir aufs Dach.
Bevor wir irgendwas machen, wir gehen jetzt aufs Dach.
Und auf dem Dach campen wir uns richtig, richtig schön ein.
So mit nem Spawn-Beacon oder allem, aber ich hab keinen Spawn-Beacon.
Nein.
Alter, das ist mir zu viel hier gerade.
Ich kann euch nicht retzen, Leute.
Fuck.
What? Von wo?
Warum spielt der immer die gleiche Waffe?
Ich spiele überhaupt nicht immer die gleiche Waffe.
Ich spiele gerade MP9, weil MP9 für Close-Quarter-Situationen richtig Pockers ist.
Richtig nicer Spawn hier.
Ach, durch die Gitter schießen.
Pass mal auf.
Six Head Rats.
Ja, gut.
Ey, will mir irgendjemand erzählen, das Game hat kein Skill-Based Matchmaking?
Was war das denn jetzt?
Pebe, Pebe, Pebe
hat uns gekillt.
war es. Pebe, Pepega.
Richtiges Schwit...
Nein, Chat.
Alles klar.
So war das nicht geplant.
Ich wollte eigentlich aufs Dach.
Gibt es mittlerweile ein paar weniger Bugs?
Ja, das kann ich
bestätigen. Es gibt weniger Bugs.
Also es gibt von 5000 Bugs
drei weniger.
Alter, Mann.
Was ist denn hier los?
Spawn down, spawn down.
Richtige Schwitze-Action angesagt hier.
Ah ja.
Angel did it again.
Dazu kann ich nur sagen,
ein extrem großer
Pains Champ.
Das Game hat nicht zu viel
CPU-Last oder so. Guck mal, ich kann nicht mal
das Fenster resizen richtig,
dass es ruckelt.
Oh Leute, Renewal.
Guckt euch an. Die M-Comps hier sind so abfuck
gesetzt. Passt mal auf.
Das sind die schlimmsten
M-Comps, die ich bisher gesehen habe.
Renewal, M-Comps.
Je nachdem, ist eigentlich egal, was man spielt.
Die M-Comps sind wirklich Pains Champ.
Guckt es euch mal an. Die anderen, muss ich sagen,
bisher, Hourglass war auch
Pains Champ. Die haben das
Gespür dafür, die schlechten Maps nicht wirklich
besser zu machen.
Aber die M-Comps auf Renewal, die sind
wirklich richtig braindead.
Gefreiter Duff, schön, dass du den Weg hergefunden hast.
Oh, ich hab
noch nie attackt. Ich hab noch nie attackt
hier auf der Map. Vielleicht ist es ja aus
Attackersicht besser. Aber aus
Defendersicht sind die M-Comps richtig blöd.
Richtig
blöde. Ich leg jetzt,
ich mach jetzt keine Legehennen. Ich geh jetzt aufs Dach.
Oh oh.
Ne, ich mach doch. Okay, Leute.
Ich mach doch. Oh oh oh oh oh oh.
Oh oh, mit dem Fenster sind 50
tausend Gegner. Lull.
Haha.
Gangway. Messer ins Gesicht,
Mann. Alter.
Ich hab, ich hab, ich weiß überhaupt nicht, was hier grad
abgeht. Terminated. Irgendwas,
irgendwas hat mich gekillt.
Ich weiß nicht mal, was mich getötet hat gerade.
Monkeys.
Ich brenne.
Warum brenne ich?
Meine Güte.
Der 37-jährige Boomer muss
es mal wieder richten hier. Ich seh schon.
So, Leute. Jetzt geh ich aufs Dach. Dachstelz.
Mir egal, was hier mit M-Comps abgeht. Dachstelz.
Nein.
Lass mich in Ruhe. Fuck.
Ich wollte aufs Dach hoch.
Ist der Chat nach wie vor Team-Only? Ne.
Squad-Team-Party. Also.
Ja. Ja. Team-Only.
Ich kann nix machen. Sorry. Ich kann mich da nicht retzen.
Wenn ich nicht retze, dann bin ich...
Fuck, Mann.
Ich stecke in der Wand.
Ihr könnt mich nicht retzen.
Siehste.
Schreckt.
Oh, ne. Wir müssen wieder ran.
Erst mal
alles wegsprellen mit der Minigun.
Oh.
Ich würde gerne
was treffen. Kommst.
Boris, Mann.
Boris.
Okay. Ja. Ja.
Nein. Rennt hier nur rein. Keine Probleme. Easy.
Rennt ihr alle nur in meine
Minigun. Ist schon in Ordnung.
By the way. Ich habe acht oder so gekillt.
Wir sollten doch jetzt eigentlich da rankommen, oder?
Oh, nice. Wir haben's.
Oh, fuck.
Was ist denn hier los?
MonkaS, Alter.
Ist das 16 vs. 16
vs. 16?
Wie geht denn das?
Das ist ja schlimmer als Battlefield 3
Revive Train, Mann.
Lull.
The fuck.
MonkaS.
Ich höre 50 Gegner um mich drum herum.
Ich kann nämlich nicht bewegen.
Es geht nicht. Es ist nicht möglich, mich zu
bewegen.
Okay. Wir müssen Seitenwechsel machen, Leute.
Wir müssen Seitenwechsel machen.
Sagt's euch.
Sagt's euch. Oh, oh. Oh, oh. Da kommt ein Auto.
Richtiges
Schwitzer-Gameplay, Mann.
Jetzt richtiges Schwitzer-Gameplay, Leute.
Ich sag's euch. Ich muss aufs Dach.
Ich muss aufs Dach. Wenn ich aufs
Dach komme, dann können die bei mir spawnen.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Okay, GG.
Leute, ihr könnt bei mir aufs Dach.
Ich habe keine Muni mehr, aber das passt.
Ich glaube, hier kommt auch gleich was
hoch.
Ich bin halt nicht
der geilste so vom Dach da jetzt.
Aber
haben wir irgendwie...
Boris!
Wie geht das?
Falls ihr reinspawnt, wären so
ein paar Kisten ganz gut.
Ammo-Boxes.
Oh, ne. Jetzt muss ich nachladen, Mann.
Jetzt. Oh, nice.
Ammo-Box-Wars. Ammo-Box-Wars.
Pog. Die Pog-Box ist da, Leute.
Oh, das... Okay. Das können wir
easy defend, Leute. Easy defend von hier oben. Easy defend.
Oh, wir sehen's nicht. Scheiße.
Wir sehen's nicht, Mann.
Aber wir können die...
Wir können die ran gehen.
Okay. PP-Ga-Aimed. Richtig PP-Ga-Aimed.
Aber die kommen nicht ran, so.
In the ask shoot it.
Motion.
Oh. Von hinten!
Nein!
Aber zum Glück haben wir noch mehr Leute hier oben.
Einer müsste noch
leben von uns, oder?
Ey, shit. Aber wir haben's. Wir haben's.
Pog. So, passt mal auf. Die nächsten
M-Comps sind richtig, richtig
hängengeblieben.
Wir können... Wir haben nämlich... Guck mal, hier sind die M-Comps
und wir haben komplett High-Ground auf dem Dach.
Das ist richtig dumm.
Oder auf der anderen Seite ist einer.
Das vorher war natürlich
selbstverständlich kein Headshot.
Also das war richtig PP-Ga
hier. Vielleicht aber auch nur,
weil SBMM nicht gegriffen hat.
Mensch, lasst mich in Ruhe.
Oh, oh.
Okay. Es ist
doch nicht so PP-Ga, wie ich's gedacht hab.
Also
das letzte Mal war das mega easy.
Alter.
Brrrrrr.
Vielleicht hab ich auch Glück.
Aber die müssen sich halt mit dem Dach
beschäftigen. Die müssen sich
halt mit dem Dach beschäftigen. Deswegen.
Ah, ne. Wir haben hier nix zum retzen.
26. Was hab ich denn da
alles gebasht?
Ach, das war... Ah, ja.
Doch. Oh, oh, oh.
Das war die Geschichte
mit der Minigun, ne?
Die Gegner sind
richtig gut, man. Was ist denn hier los?
Das ist ja gar nicht...
Das ist ja gar nicht so easy, easy
durchgerushe.
Jawoll, machen platt.
Oh, da hinten sind noch mehr.
Nein. Shit.
Ah, ich warte mal.
Pogaster sind zwei Stück dahinter.
Da machst du nix.
Das ist bestimmt SBMM, Leute. Ich sag's
euch. Das ist SBMM.
Okay, der flankt mich
jetzt von links. Ich sag's euch.
Okay. Achtung.
Big brain time.
Hahaha.
Ey, wo?
Alter, wo kommst du schon wieder her?
Wo kommt der schon
wieder her, Mann?
Hansjürgen40plus
möchte nicht gebasht werden. Weißt du, was das Schlimmste ist?
Dass Hansjürgen von
37plus gebasht wird hier gerade.
Da soll er sich halt
einfach mal anstrengen.
Oh, oh.
Wie krass die Gegner
auf einmal sind.
Ganz ehrlich,
ich hab Renewal bisher nur erlebt als
Easy Mode Deluxe
für die Attacker.
Das ist, das ist richtig,
das ist mir richtig neu hier,
dass man... Oh, hier Pogaster.
Richtig guter Spawn, jawoll.
Big brain time.
Massive brain, Alter.
Massive brain.
Okay.
Aber trotzdem, trotzdem. Nice, nice, nice
Spawn.
Du bist, Max, du bist nicht der normale
Pogaster.
Also, das war's.
Wenn ich mal zocke, eher
ein guter.
Bin ich froh, wenigstens irgendetwas
muss man ja können.
Wohingegen das restliche Team schon mal gar nix kann.
Captain Pogaster ist mega schwitzig.
Wir gehen nach der Runde auch raus
und suchen uns
ne neue Lobby.
Haha, sag eu, geht ja nicht anders.
Ich sag,
SPMM ist hier angesagt.
Wie wäre es dann mit sterben, Mensch?
Okay. Oder auch nicht.
Aber massive
revive, massive revive.
Jetzt aber.
Gib ihm. Lege Henne.
Alter, die
jumpshotten mich schon.
Was ist hier los, wenn das nicht
SPMM ist?
Die jumpshotten einen schon rein, Mann.
Kick weight, Alter.
Wo sind wir denn hier gelandet?
What the fuck?
Du spawnst, du bist down.
Einfach just win.
Just win, Leute. Just take the objective.
Einfach das objective tanken.
Ist doch easy.
Wir müssen... Der Ansager.
Der Ansager sagt doch schon, was er sagt.
Just take the objective.
Nee, nee. Hier gehe ich nicht lang.
Mann, Alter. Die Gegner.
Was geht mit denen ab?
Was geht denn hier ab?
Ich meine, wir sind schon ziemlich gut
die Runde, ja?
Es gibt keinen Rang in dem Spiel.
Zumindest keinen Rang, der angezeigt wird.
ESL Match Toin.
Okay. Wir suchen
mal neu, Leute. Wir suchen mal neu.
Ja, das ist
ESL Scrim.
Was war das hier wieder?
Ich such mal neu.
Ich kann leider nicht raus, weil wir uns die tollen
Outro-Sequenzen anschauen müssen.
Vom Gegner, der hat...
Der hatte S003-Rang.
Hä?
Was, der hatte als Level S003?
Vielleicht war es ein Hacker?
Vielleicht war das eine Hacker-Lobby.
Das kann ja durchaus sein.
Vielleicht war das wirklich eine Hacker-Lobby.
Ich würde es mir nicht ausschließen, dass das nicht schon geht.
Garantiert. Das ging wahrscheinlich zur Beta schon.
Ach so, das ist nach Level 99.
Okay. Ist normal.
Dann habe ich nichts gesagt.
Guck mal.
Ich habe einen Reward unlocked.
So.
Suchen wir mal die nächste.
Wobei, Zack, wir warten ganz kurz,
dass die ganzen krassen Schwitzer
schon ein anderes Game haben.
Ich würde sagen, es lohnt sich
für 40 Euro.
Ach, ist das schon runtergesetzt, oder was?
Gibt es das im Sale jetzt schon?
Also, wenn es das jetzt
wirklich schon im Sale gibt,
dann ist das ziemlich
klar, sie wollen
Verkaufszahlen.
Cheebaiten.
Ach so, auf Keyseiten.
Wasch.
Leute, ihr könnt mich doch jetzt nicht
alleine spielen lassen.
Jetzt weiß ich nicht, wen ich da gerade noch invited habe.
Also angeblich wart ihr alle noch drin.
Jedes Game, halbes ESL.
Ihr habt das eben gesehen.
Die haben mich gejumpshottet.
Wo kommen wir denn bitte schön dahin?
Der hat einen um die Ecke gejumpshottet.
Das ist normalerweise was,
was du hier nur siehst bei irgendwelchen
Call-of-Duty-Schwitzer-Lobbys.
Ne, ihr seid doch alle da.
Oh, Our Class,
Leute.
Our Class hat mich auch nicht überzeugt.
Da müssen wir jetzt mal was anderes...
Komm, wir gucken mal, wie die PP29
jetzt ist.
Langer Lachs.
Passt.
Ironside-Enjoyer am Start.
So ultra verziehen tut
die doch jetzt eigentlich auch nicht.
Hast du schon den
Skinskin gesehen? Den haben sie doch wieder aus dem Spiel entfernt,
dachte ich.
Hier, jetzt schon wieder los hier.
So, B sollte
eigentlich secure sein.
Oh, der Pantsman ist am Start.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Der macht lege Hände.
Looooooow
und nix wie weg.
Aua. Ich dachte, man kann sich
vielleicht hier hochhucken, aber nee, kann man nicht.
Das ist
16 vs 16.
Nicht 12 vs 12.
Boah, shit.
Ach, du kannst einem deine Meinung zu dem Game abgeben
in der Mail. Pogax, mach das mal.
Die bekommen da bestimmt sicherlich nur
von allen Seiten sehr, sehr nette
Mails.
Sag mal, ist wieder
ESL-Match angesagt jetzt?
Oh, die haben A gelegt.
Lege Hände ist am Start.
Die lege Hände.
Wie kommt der Dude denn jetzt auf einmal
hinter uns?
Guck mal, wie die jumpen alle schon.
10 vs 16 Fahrzeuge.
Ja, es gibt nicht viele Fahrzeuge.
Hier auf Our Class gibt's jetzt ein bisschen mehr.
Normalerweise hast du entweder gar keine Fahrzeuge
oder halt jede Menge Jeeps
und ab und zu mal irgendwas,
was anderes.
Äh. Wo ist denn B?
MonkaS?
Ich checke überhaupt nicht,
wo hier was ist.
By the way, Leute, seht ihr die Wahnsinnsliebe
zu Detail in diesen Gebäuden?
Sieht halt aus, als hat das
irgendein Mapper erstellt
in einer Viertelstunde.
Ich hab beim besten Willen keine Ahnung,
wo überhaupt was los ist hier gerade.
Da hinten ist irgendwas los.
Außen? Da?
Ah!
Haha, voll in
Scatter reingesprungen.
Scatter.
Jetzt hat Twitch wieder was, was sie muten können in meinem Bot.
Okay, das ist tatsächlich nicht so einfach
mit dem Ding, was zu hitten mittlerweile.
Die haben sie doch ganz gut genervt.
Richtig ESL-Game wieder.
Ja.
Sieht aus, wie prozedural
generiert, ja. Finde ich auch.
Gerade auf, gerade
gerade auf Our Class.
Boah. Monka.
Ne, hier geht's
gar nicht. Geht's hier rum?
Hallo? Game?
Haha. Out of Map.
Lul. Aber ich glaube,
wir haben gleich gewonnen. Ich krieg
bei dieser Runde absolut nichts geschissen und ich weiß
gar nicht, wo was abgeht, aber
immerhin, immerhin.
Oh, ich glaub, ah. Ich glaub, die machen Legehennen.
Oh, oh.
The Pants Man.
Das war dumm.
Bist gespannt, wie sich Rush spielen lässt?
Ja. So wie du's
hier siehst. Ziemlich
ESL-Scrim-mäßig.
Okay. Also ich bin
grad wahnsinnig überfordert,
weil ich keine Ahnung hab, wo hier überhaupt was abgeht.
What the?
Achso, das war nicht der.
Wollt grad sagen.
Was ist denn hier grad los, man?
Das ist wirklich...
Das ist ja härter als irgendwelche...
Wie gesagt,
irgendwelche ESL-Scrims
oder sonst was.
Lul.
Zumal ich absolut nicht einschätzen kann...
Oh, das ist das
Boris-Boris-Geschütz.
Ey!
What the fuck, man?
Meine Elo ist zu hoch, ja?
Sieht so aus.
Okay, okay.
Okay, Freund, Feinderkennung, Pog.
Irgendwo ist doch hier angeblich
was. Irgendwo ist doch hier was.
Wie kommt man denn jetzt hier aufs erste Level?
Hier, oder?
Aber hier ist nix mehr.
Ich glaub, wir haben's,
Leute. Elf.
Poggers.
Wir haben's gleich geschafft. Ich hab nichts gemacht,
außer einen Kill, aber Sirius Max und Captain Pang
haben's gecarried.
Ich versuch euch zu retzen, Jungs.
Ah, Tür zu. Lul.
Okay, der ist im Treppenhaus, der Typ.
Ich dachte, der sitzt hier unten rum.
Oh, da oben kam er! Habt ihr gesehen?
Jetzt kam er die Treppe runter.
Gibt es etwa wieder ein Scoreboard? Nö, natürlich nicht.
Kein Scoreboard.
I'm just better than anyone else.
Beleuchtung hat das Spiel
indoor gefühlt gar nicht.
Was hab ich denn schönes gemacht?
What made Revived?
Mindblown.
Gab's Performance-Änderungen?
Tja.
Gute Frage.
Es läuft nicht besser oder schlechter als vorher.
Die einzige Sache ist halt 16 vs 16.
Das ist ein bisschen flüssiger.
Gab es von Seiten DICE eine Begründung
für das nicht vorhandene Scoreboard?
Ja.
Es ist ein Legacy-Feature, haben sie gesagt.
Was? Oh, Kaleidoskop!
Das hab ich noch nie gespielt.
Also hier, Rush.
Die haben gesagt, es ist ein Legacy-Feature.
Warum? Was sie darunter verstehen?
Weiß man nicht.
Aber es ist ein Legacy-Feature.
Was auch immer. Keine Ahnung.
Müssten wir mal in Schweden anrufen.
Äh, Gelne Sis?
Nein, ich würd's mir jetzt noch nicht kaufen.
Das Spiel hat im Prinzip auch mit
Update 3 noch alle Probleme,
die ich in meinem Video angesprochen hab.
Nur, du kannst sie
jetzt quasi ausblenden,
wenn du ein bisschen 16 vs 16 spielst.
Aber selbst da merkst du am
M-Complacement und an den Maps,
dass das einfach nicht da...
Ach, guck mal!
...nicht so wahnsinnig gut durchdacht ist.
Ja, links und rechts schauen mit der Maus
ist definitiv ein Legacy-Feature,
deswegen geht das bei manchen Leuten nicht,
weil es abgeschaltet wurde.
Das war ja so, ne?
Also ich weiß nicht, inwieweit ich das mitgekriegt hab,
ähm, also, Maus-Look war
disabled, oder beziehungsweise verbuggt.
Bei einigen Leuten.
Maus-Look ist auch eindeutig ein
Legacy-Feature.
Bin mir nicht ganz sicher, wo der Typ ist.
Ich schmeiß mal ein paar... Oh, da kommt was.
Haha!
Oh!
Okay, jetzt hab ich ein Problem. Ich seh nix.
Alter, wie die aimen!
Was geht mit denen ab?
Das ist, wie gesagt, ESL-Match 2.0.
Ich komm aus dem Rauch raus,
der Typ zieht instant rechts
auf mich rüber.
Krasser Scheiß
hier wieder, äh.
Nee, nee, retzt mich nicht, hier oben rennen noch Gegner rum.
Aber ich glaube, es geht jetzt.
Ich glaube, es geht.
Ich mein, hier haben wir, denke ich, ganz gute Chancen.
Das ist halt wieder
ein wahnsinniger Painz-Champ-Posi.
Einfach alles offen.
Nein.
Ah, wir haben einen Panzer und die Angreifer nicht.
Okay, dann haben wir schon mal gewonnen.
Moment, das ist...
Achtung, Achtung, passt mal auf!
Extrem Six Head Play.
So was geht nur in
16 vs 16, Leute.
Überall anders ist das nicht möglich.
Okay, ich weiß überhaupt nicht, wo sie sind.
Wo sind sie denn?
Wo sind sie denn alle?
Das war clip-würdig.
Ah, einer nur. Hätte ich die zwei da erwischt,
dann wäre das richtig Proc gewesen.
Oder drei sogar.
Auf der anderen Seite, niemand will
irgendwelche Highlight-Montage-Szenen
aufs Battlefield, glaube ich.
Meint ihr, Leute, würden sie sich auf YouTube
irgendeine coole Highlight-Montage angucken?
Also, Montage, insofern einfach nur die besten Clips
so zehn Minuten hintereinander
geschnitten.
Ich glaube, das hätte am Ende 8K-Aufrufe oder so.
Nee, glaube ich auch nicht.
Nur Fail-Compilation.
Battlefield-Clips gehen nicht.
Die einzigen Battlefield-Clips, die gehen, sind
Bug-Compilations und sowas.
Das geht nicht.
Okay, ich glaube, die Runde haben wir
easy, Leute. Doch keine ESL-Lobby.
Die haben wir easy.
Musst du gar nichts machen.
Ich renne jetzt einfach mal kurz in die Gegner,
weil ich gucken will, wie weit man hier rennen kann.
Sinnigerweise.
Ja, bis hier, hä?
Ich meine, das ist auch
Werder's... Guck mal, das ist einfach nur
offen auf der Map. Was hat man sich
denn dabei gedacht?
Ja doch, die Map ist
eigentlich extrem Defense.
Guck mal, es ist einfach komplett
offen.
Ohne, dass du irgendwie eine Deckung hast.
Was sollen die Gegner denn machen?
Ich guck mal, ob es irgendwelche Attacker-Wege gibt.
Ich schau mal kurz.
Also die Attacker könnten, glaube ich, ganz
außen lang flanken. Okay.
Das würde vielleicht funktionieren, aber es ist auch
komplett flach.
So, es ist komplett flach.
Die könnten hier 30 Kilometer außen lang flanken
und dann 30 Kilometer übers Feld auf A rennen.
Das wird keiner freiwillig machen.
So.
Ansonsten können sie
vielleicht noch Fahrzeug-Fights gewinnen. Okay.
Hier ist nichts mehr. Hier geht's, glaube ich, nicht weiter.
Der Tunnel ist, glaube ich, komplett out of
Dings. Ja.
Okay.
Also das ist wirklich nicht so clever gemacht.
Not...
Not-File-Fat.
Oh nein, die haben gelegt.
Die Legehände ist am Start, Leute.
Ich will das jetzt nicht verlieren.
Fuck, ich noob. Ich habe nicht getroffen.
Richtig dumm.
Three-Head.
Ironside-Enjoyer.
Aber ich glaube, wir defusen.
Vergleich das mal mit der Mario-Rush-Karte,
wo es auch einen grünen Park
gab am Anfang.
Was? Mario-Card?
Was? Ach, nicht Mario-Card.
Metro. Warum habe ich Mario-Card
gelesen?
Mein Hirn setzt schon komplett aus.
Metro-Rush.
Ich habe Mario-Card gelesen, Mann.
Ja, das ist halt das Problem, wenn man nur mit
einem Auge auf den Chat guckt.
Ja, das stimmt.
Guck mal, da ist er wieder. Der will wieder gebasht werden.
Nein.
Oh.
Von allen Seiten.
Hat das Update Performance?
Performance.
Die Performance verbessert?
Ne, das sieht nur so aus,
weil 16 vs. 16 ist.
Anstatt 64 vs. 64.
Okay, die haben es tatsächlich geschafft,
das Ding in die Luft zu sprengen.
Wir defenden jetzt einfach. Die haben bloß noch 7 Tickets, Leute.
Oh, oh.
Die legen B.
Okay, wir machen den
Dance, den Rush-Dance.
Jawoll.
Rush-Dance erfolgreich.
Hä?
Wo ist der Dude?
Ah, Wind.
Hm.
Battlefield-Top-Plays.
Ich hätte selbst genug coole Plays.
Aber wie gesagt,
Battlefield 2042-Sachen will keiner sehen.
Das einzige, was richtig gut läuft,
ist irgendwelche
Bug-Compilations oder so.
Oder halt, du bist der Mega-
Highlights-Channel und
machst es zu mehreren Games.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass
die Only-Highlight-Channels irgendwie
da
groß reingehen,
was Subzahlen
und so angeht und Aufrufe.
Hat das Update
irgendwas gerettet? Naja.
Im Kern hat sich
eigentlich nichts getan.
Es ist aber Rush.
Und das Gute ist, noch nicht mal, dass es Rush ist,
weil M-Complacement und die Maps sind immer noch nicht gut.
Das richtig Gute ist, dass es
16 vs. 16 ist
und eben kein Clusterfuck
64 vs. 64.
Das ist eigentlich das Beste
da dran.
Da sieht man mal, dass so Battlefield
im Kern eigentlich ziemlich
unverwüstlich ist.
Egal, was man dem Game antut.
Wenn du so ein paar
Parameter richtig einstellst,
geht's. Und ist
im Prinzip immer noch
eigentlich ganz okay.
Und jetzt überlegt euch mal,
wenn es schon so unverwüstlich ist, wenn man jetzt
einfach noch was Richtiges und was Gutes
und was Big Brain Zusammenpassendes
macht, dann
könnte das ein richtig
geiles Game werden. Aber Battlefield 2042
wird es nie wieder werden.
Also ich meine Battlefield an sich
nicht, Battlefield 2042.
Battlefield 2042 wird, glaube ich,
nie irgendwie
ein super herausragendes Game werden.
Auch wenn sie gesagt haben, sie planen
das zu supporten für Years to Come.
Ich hab da so meine Zweifel.
Serious Max hat wieder Probleme,
in die Lobby reinzukommen, weil
Battlefield. Okay, hier müssen wir
jetzt. Oje, was?
Alter.
Nein.
Wo ist denn der Dude?
Ach, der ist unter mir jetzt.
Oje.
Ist der da drin jetzt schon, oder wie?
Okay.
Oh, ich hätte ihn warten sollen.
Ich hätte warten sollen, bis der Rests.
Nur um dann beide zu killen.
Die sind gut im, die sind nicht
nur gut im Zeitplan, die sind ahead of
schedule, haben wir doch gelernt.
Ahead of schedule.
Nein.
Achtung.
YOLO.
Okay, dass der Grappling
manchmal verbuggt ist, nervt mich.
Hier war doch noch einer eben.
Oh. Ammo leer.
Ammo, Leute.
Ich brauche Mun.
Haben sie in Gears of War immer gesagt.
Gears of War war, glaube ich,
eines der schlecht übersetzten Spiele
aller Zeiten.
Guck mal, guck mal hier ist der. Nein.
Die Kiste ist einfach despawned.
Captain Porgas, ich kann dich nicht holen.
Ich hab das.
Ich zeige euch jetzt mal den besten Spot auf der
ganzen Map.
Aber der klappt nicht immer.
Der klappt nicht immer.
Hier oben.
Wenn die Wand kaputt ist,
wenn, ah ne, jetzt hat es nicht geklappt.
Wenn die Wand kaputt ist, niemand guckt da oben hin.
Niemand.
Wenn hier drinnen Action ist, niemand.
Guck mal.
Ja. Niemand. Niemand wird hier hochgucken.
Ich bleibe jetzt hier einfach stehen.
Und werfe Motion Sensors.
Und wenn einer reinkommt,
wird da, wird da hipfired.
Und gleich machen sie die Wand kaputt
und rechnet auch keiner mit mir hier oben.
Easy.
Guck mal.
Schön in die Ecke campen.
Beste Pose.
Ja.
Okay.
Guck mal, da rennen sie da vor rum.
Next. Motion Sensor.
Ah, yes.
Die Drohne.
Was?
Oh nein, der hat die Tür zugemacht, bevor ich killen konnte.
Was soll das hier?
High Octane Gameplay, Leute.
High Octane Gameplay.
Findet ihr nicht auch, dass das
absolut massive, skilligste
skilligste Gameplay aller Zeiten ist?
Ich hab den High Ground, ja.
Ich hab den High Ground.
Oh.
Zack. Zack.
Kommt rein, Leute. Kommt rein.
Oh, jetzt spawnen sie sogar noch hier oben.
Vollgas.
Ich brauch Ammo.
Mal gucken.
Ne, hat nicht funktioniert.
Egal.
Wir können ja einfach wieder hoch.
Das klappt aber nicht immer.
Seht ihr? Das ist trickreich.
Da musst du schon
als
richtig Eleven Head sein, dass das funktioniert.
Vielleicht von hier?
Ah, nice.
Achtung, Achtung.
Oh.
Der sieht mich nicht.
Der sieht mich nicht, Leute. Der sieht mich nicht.
Ich beweg mich nicht, der sieht mich nicht.
What?
Die sind despawned.
Five Head.
Five Head Position, Leute.
Five Head Position, ich sag's euch.
Ich schau mal, ob ich rüber kann.
Five Head Position.
Next Level Shit.
Ich glaube, ich muss runter.
Shit.
Da gibt's Bots, aber hier gerade nicht, anscheinend.
666 is a cheater, sagt er.
Siehste, da hat uns,
da hat uns noch nicht mal
in Six Head Position jetzt was
gebracht.
666 is a cheater?
Ja, tja, ha.
Wir haben hier ein Scoreboard, wo wir
nicht sehen, was wir die Gegner so treiben.
Dementsprechend
werden wir das überhaupt nicht überprüfen können, ob das vielleicht
ein Cheater ist oder nicht.
Äh.
Game? Hallo?
Warum ist das
jetzt so auf einmal off, off, offzone?
Alles klar.
Einfach, einfach ins Aus
befördert.
Alter, einfach mitten, mitten hier
gesetzt.
Vettel, ich retz dich.
Einfach mitten die Linie gesetzt hier, Mensch.
Was ist das denn hier für krasses
Map Design wieder?
Six Head Design.
Das grenzt schon fast an
Eleven Head Design hier.
Oh, da ist ein Panzer.
Panzer gestuckt.
What?
Das Two-Tapper Girl hat mich
Two-Tapped, wie es aussieht.
Ohne jetzt erkannt zu haben, von wo.
Two-Tapper
Girl. Nice.
Das Gurrel. Sorry, das Gurrel.
Das Two-Tapper Gurrel.
Ja.
Ey, jawoll, auf geht's, volle Pulle.
Nice.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was hier besser
zu defenden ist.
Wahrscheinlich hängt's
davon ab, wo die Gegner lang pushen. Ich glaube nicht, dass es
hier wirklich so einen großen
Unterschied macht.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Mensch!
Nimm halt deine beschissene Waffe raus und
kill den.
Und mach nicht erst drei Stunden geile
Akrobatik mit der MP9 in den Händen,
bis du anfangen kannst zu schießen.
Guck, da ist es. Seht ihr?
Das Two-Tapper Gurrel.
Aerochall, dankeschön für den Sub.
Oh, Six Head Rats. Nein, ein Rass.
Geht nicht. Rass geht nicht, oder?
Hinter euch, Leute, hinter euch. Nein.
Ich spawn lieber bei euch rein.
Das klappt so, glaube ich, nicht.
Was?
Ich glaube, es geht los.
Das Two-Tapper Gurrel.
Das musst du jetzt dran glauben.
Ein wenig veraimt, aber trotzdem
ganz gut gemacht, würde ich sagen.
Ich dachte, da liegt einer. Habt ihr auch
gedacht, hier liegt einfach einer?
Hm, B kriegen wir nicht mehr, Leute.
B kriegen wir nicht.
B kriegen wir nicht. Captain Peng, ich hole dich.
Nein.
Jawoll.
Fuck.
Wow.
Das Two-Tapper Gurrel. Das geht voll ab.
Guckt es euch an.
Oh, oh.
Ich bräuchte Ammo. Haben wir hier irgendwo was?
Wonka. Oh, oh.
Fuck.
Ich dachte, ich komme da irgendwie rüber.
Nice.
Shoot Rass.
Was ist das hier?
Jetzt können wir das Ding mal ausprobieren.
Boah, das lasert
ja, Mann. Das ist ja pock.
Und ich spiele
MP9, die übelst rumzieht.
Das Ding lasert
ja richtig.
Oh, oh. Oh, oh.
Ich dachte, das sind eigene Leute.
Ne, Halo spielen wir heute nicht mehr.
Wir sind das Dawnbreaker Squad.
Wir müssen das jetzt hier carryen.
Der Morg...
Das Morgendämmerer Squad.
Erinnert sich noch einer an diese...
Oh, jetzt wird aber B ganz schön voll.
Erinnert sich noch einer an die grandiose Übersetzung
aus Battlefield 4?
Der Morgendämmerer.
Oh, Mist.
Oh, da kommt gleich noch mehr.
Ich kann da nicht rüber.
Ja, alles klar.
Aber, die gehen gut durch
hier. Hm.
Das müssen wir jetzt...
Wir müssen jetzt erstmal den
Advanced... Was?
Advanced... Nein.
Wir müssen die Gegner am Advancen hindern.
Jetzt hab ich's.
Mehr Denglish in einen Satz packen.
Achso, hier ist ja wieder die Map zu Ende.
Ja, ist ja gut jetzt, Game.
Come on, sterbt halt mal.
Oh, oh. Oh, oh.
Da kommen 5 Milliarden Gegner gleich.
Das Two-Tapper-Gurl ist bestimmt auch dabei.
Nein.
Two-Tapped wieder. Guck hier.
Da, da ist es.
Hat's mich gebasht wieder.
Massive Res.
Oh.
Okay.
Alter, da ist das Geschwitze wieder.
Kommt sich ja vor wie in Warzone, schau.
In Warz.
Ne, Warz war das andere.
Von wo?
Von...
Wo?
Wer hat mich denn bitteschön jetzt gekillt?
Rushbog?
Ja. Also Chat, ganz ehrlich,
wenn ich, also
in Ermangelung
Alternativen
ist Rush noch der Modus, der mir aktuell
am meisten zusagt. Ja, das stimmt.
Muss weg.
Es ist einfach nicht so krasser Clusterfuck
wie die anderen.
Und das ist schon mal ein riesiger Vorteil.
Moment, der ist doch hier drinnen.
Das hat er sich so gedacht.
Du hast nirgends Deckung.
Ja, das ist das tolle Mapdesign
von BF2042.
Guck mal, da kommt was.
Oh, Ammo. Gib mir Ammo.
Achtung. Big Brain. Move.
Oh, oh.
Massive Brain.
Nein.
Oh, oh. Oh, oh.
Oh, oh.
Das ist zu viel. Es ist einfach zu viel.
Ich muss auch ESL Jumpshotten
um die Ecke wieder anfangen.
Es ist einfach
zu viel gerade.
Ja, man kann
in Bot Games richtig gut Waffe leveln.
Ja, das war schon seit Release so.
Deswegen verstehe ich ja auch nicht, warum sie
in Portal die XP
deaktiviert haben. Da muss ich das mal überlegen.
In Portal spielst du gegen
echte Spieler
und kannst theoretisch boosten.
Aber du kannst auch Singleplayer gegen Bots boosten.
Also, warum
solltest du dann nicht in Portal gegen
echte Spieler spielen können?
Also, wisst ihr, wie ich meine? Wenn du
eh boosten kannst,
warum dann nicht wenigstens noch gegen echte
Spieler erlauben? Versteht ihr,
wie ich meine? Das ist eigentlich total bescheuert.
Nein.
Du siehst mich nicht. Ah, shit.
LMG legit.
L-L-C-M-G.
Nein. Lege Henne.
Dachte, wir haben es jetzt
an dem Objective.
Ja, die Bots, ja, die Bots
sind für Waffenleveln
gut, ja. Das reicht ja schon.
Ja, hallo. Stern, please.
Aber für Attachments
reicht es ja schon.
Oh, hier kommen gleich 50
Billiarden Gegner runter, Leute.
Seht ihr das? Meine Güte.
Kommt euch das vor, wie 16 vs 16?
Ist das eine falsche Anzeige?
Das kommt einem so viel vor.
Huge rest, huge rest.
Okay, wenn wir Glück haben.
Ich kann mich nicht runter
kriechen. Ah, yes.
Excellent. Verstecksor.
Poggers versteckt,
Leute. Mich sieht keiner.
Mich kann
einfach keiner sehen.
Unmöglich.
Unmöglich, mich zu sehen.
Was?
Du kannst mich nicht sehen.
Was soll das hier?
Und ich habe ihn ja
überhaupt nicht erkannt.
Da sieht er mich einfach.
Muss
Wallhack sein, genau.
Das ist irgendein Motion Sensor gewesen.
Weil das Game
das ja eh permanent auf der Minimap hat.
Also, Suppressor
bringt gar nichts.
Suppressor ist
wirklich total overrated,
outdated in dem Spiel.
Ich weiß
gar nicht, wie der Eingang da vorne aussieht,
wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Ich camp mich jetzt hier hinter die Kiste.
Glaub's nicht.
Easy.
Sowas kannst du halt 16 vs 16
machen, aber im Leben nicht 32
32.
Was? Die haben schon Legehände gemacht.
Ich fasse es nicht. Die sind schon am Start.
Alter.
Wie schnell waren die denn bitteschön hier am Start?
Ich mach da noch irgendwie...
Ah, wir haben die Fused, okay.
Ich mach da noch
sonst wie Action vorne und die sind schon wieder am Start.
Wurde Maus-Input verbessert? Nö.
Auf jeden Fall.
Jawoll. Jawoll.
Die Fused. Die Fused. Die Fused.
Die Fused. Die Fused. Die Fused. Die Fused.
Die Fused. Die Fused. Oh, Entschärfungshähne
am Start.
Das war close.
Close AF,
Leute. Close AF.
Sag ich euch.
Das kann man sogar mal clippen.
Das war wirklich knapp.
Ja, Durchbruch
kannst du nicht spielen mit 128.
Wirklich.
Fuck.
Da konnte ich jetzt nicht mit rechnen.
Wir müssen eigentlich nur uns alle
fett stacken.
Auf ein M
kommen und dann easy win.
Was Chat? Würdest du sagen, dass sie sich
mit der Schadensbegrenzung Mühe gegeben haben?
Ach, du meinst, dass
sie das Game noch irgendwie versuchen zu retten?
Nö. Nicht wirklich.
Sie haben halt
ein paar M-Comps gesetzt.
War es mehr oder weniger.
Ich diffuse. Ich diffuse. Ich diffuse.
Ich bin der krasse Diffuse-Gott.
Nice.
Und hoch hier.
Was ist denn hier hinten?
Wo ist der Dude?
Ah, der muss hier unten drunter irgendwo sein.
Äh, okay.
Die sollen sich auf die wichtigen Sachen
konzentrieren. Das Problem ist, dass die ja schon
komplett in Verzug sind mit dem Game, weil es
in so einem scheiß Zustand rausgekommen ist.
Ansonsten hätte man sagen können, ja,
ihr müsst halt einfach nur Content bringen.
Aber nein. Just content.
So einfach ist es nicht.
Wir müssen das Spiel fixen
und Content bringen.
Und das für alle
erdenklichen Bereiche aus
diesem Game. Das ist tatsächlich echt
keine leichte
Herausforderung.
Wo geht hier unten was?
Okay, ich habe keine Ahnung von wo.
Ich schieße jetzt einfach mal da
in die Richtung.
Deswegen, Leute,
ist 16 vs 16
oder sagen wir mal so,
bis zu 32
einfach gut.
Du kannst Gegner richtig cool outplayen
und dich gucken dann nicht 10 von der Seite
an, wo du nicht hingeguckt hast.
Ich glaube, hieran erkennt man es jetzt eigentlich ganz gut.
Wenn du hier mit Hirn spielst,
kannst du wirklich was reißen,
weil du 2-3 Gegner killst
und dann ist gut.
Was bei 128 einfach nicht geht.
Easy Win.
Ich glaube, das war das,
was ich in meiner Zeit gespielt haben sollte.
Da müsste ich mir mal Gedanken drüber machen.
Du sollst auf jeden Fall Black Mesa spielen,
das Half-Life 1 Remake.
Weil das mittlerweile komplett fertig ist.
Mittlerweile sogar in der
Special Mega Edition oder so.
Wobei ich sagen würde,
dass nicht alles gelungen ist
in den letzten paar Levels,
aber insgesamt ist es
die mit Abstand beste Half-Life
Experience,
und das sollte wirklich jeder mal gespielt haben.
Wenn ihr mich fragt,
besser als Half-Life 2.
Kriegt man jetzt EXP bei Portal?
Weiß ich nicht.
Zumindest bei der offiziellen Playlist
bekommt man EXP, wie man hier sieht.
Ah, Manifest. Nice.
Guck mal hier, der Chat,
also hier der Ingame Chat.
Rush is actually fun.
Die Leute freuen sich.
Also zumindest Dark Twigs, der EXP.
Beste Spiele aller Zeiten,
also du sollst auch, wie gesagt,
Black Mesa spielen, wenn du auf
Story Games spielst.
Wenn du auf Story Games stehst,
und was jetzt eigentlich kein Game ist,
solltest du auf jeden Fall To The Moon spielen.
Erinnert sich noch jemand dran,
wie wir To The Moon gespielt haben im Stream?
Richtig
Biblesump?
Cryge?
Ich hab übrigens jetzt den
neuen Teil gespielt.
Imposter Factory.
Ist auch ganz okay.
Also der hat ja nach To The Moon
noch zwei neue Spiele gemacht.
Der hat Finding Paradise gemacht
und Imposter Factory.
Ist auch in Ordnung.
Aber To The Moon ist immer noch
mein Favorit dabei.
Da sind auch wieder einige Schüsse
durchgeflogen, habt ihr's gesehen?
Alter, wo?
Wo? Ach da, Mann!
Fuck!
Was ist hier oben auf dem Kran los?
Du gehst auf den Kran,
siehst einen Gegner stehen.
Fünf da.
Fünf, das ist fast die Hälfte vom Gegnerteam.
MonkaS.
Kranparty.
Der beste Spieler aller Zeiten ist sehr subjektiv
und vor allem hat's, glaube ich,
jeder schon mal gemacht.
Ich auch, aber da war's zwar nicht so durchdacht.
Heute würde ich wahrscheinlich andere nehmen.
Kann man sich eigentlich self-healen?
Oh nice, man kann sich self-healen.
Ist der da drin?
Der ist da oben drauf.
Achtung.
Alter, ich hasse es, wenn der Grappling-Hook nicht funktioniert.
Hallo, Game?
Please? Hitten?
WTF? Das ist einfach durchgeflogen.
Alter, du kannst
die hier ganz schön outmoven, oder?
Deswegen mag ich's, wenn sie ein bisschen
weniger sind. Was ist hier los?
Ah, das ist schon down.
Das ist einfach
eine ganze Ecke durchschaubarer.
Okay.
Wenn ich fünf...
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Wie? Wie?
Die Fuske.
Achtung, da ist er drin.
Das macht so Bock in dem Fall sogar,
wenn man die Gegner outmoven kann
und ein bisschen Big-Brain-Play sich
auszahlt.
Richtig nice.
Okay, jetzt blick ich da mal durch.
Die Fuske.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Jetzt bin ich, bin ich nicht.
Oh, wir haben die Fuske, nice.
So.
Fuck.
Das ist tatsächlich wie ein bisschen
vertikales Nosha-TDM hier.
Bisschen.
Wo? Ah, da oben.
Ah, jetzt von hinten.
Alter, jetzt blick ich den mal durch.
Die Krane... Ist das Krane?
Das ist Kräne, oder Kräne heißt das.
Die Kräne oben drüber machen's natürlich
ein bisschen komplexer.
Da muss man sagen, da blickt man nicht so,
nicht so einfach durch, wo was ist.
Ah, vielleicht können wir uns
auch so einen Kran hochstelzen.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, in the ass.
Krieg ich geshootet.
Okay.
Fucked up in the ass.
Over here.
Da oben ist er. Seht ihr ihn?
Oh, oh.
Okay, das war...
dumm.
Vielleicht...
Okay, okay.
Wie geh ich...
Alter. An jeder Ecke
gerade. Aber das ist wenigstens noch
halbwegs überschaubar.
Also das... mit 16 vs 16
geht das wirklich klar.
Da kann ich mich nicht beschweren.
Aber vielleicht schaffen wir es jetzt an der ersten
Base zu defenden. Wir haben ja nur noch B.
Und aktuell konzentrieren die sich
witzigerweise eigentlich auf die komplett falsche
Seite, lul.
Hallo, ich will aussteigen. Game. Ich will aussteigen.
Game, ich will aussteigen. Aussteigen.
Aussteigen.
Hallo. Spiel.
Aus.
Will aussteigen.
Ich darf nicht aussteigen.
Es ist... es ist kaputt.
What?
Was ist jetzt los?
Ach, jetzt geht's.
Hey, du.
Ich wollte es eigentlich schon ausmachen,
aber ich kann nicht. Ich muss mich gerade aufs Spiel konzentrieren.
Ich muss mich gerade aufs Spiel konzentrieren.
Alter, ich krieg Anfälle?
Oh, nee!
Nein!
Noch 2 Tickets.
Öh...
Die haben's doch gehabt.
Die wurden gerade um den Sieg gebatet, die Gegner.
Hatten die es nicht?
Ach, das andere hatten wir noch?
Nee, das andere war doch weg, oder?
Ach, wir hatten das andere noch.
Dann habe ich es nicht gecheckt.
Ich dachte, das andere M-Com ist schon weg.
Deswegen habe ich auch vorhin gesagt,
die müssen nur noch B holen.
Wurde nicht auf der Map angezeigt.
Ach so, dann ist ja klar.
Kann man ja auch nicht erwarten,
dass das funktioniert.
Wo kämen wir denn da hin?
Chad sagt, hey, wäre es sinnvoll,
bei einem i7-7700 auf eine RTX 3070 oder 80 zu hoffen,
falls die Preise jemals...
Der 7700 ist ja quasi der Vorläufer von meinem.
Ich habe einen 8700.
Ganz ehrlich, je nachdem,
was du jetzt für eine Grafikkarte hast,
würde ich erst mal warten.
Ansonsten, gerade wenn du Low-Settings spielst
und High-FPS, kann sich das durchaus lohnen.
Aber je nachdem, was du jetzt hast.
Auf der anderen Seite, wenn es nicht akut ist,
kannst du auch warten,
bis es irgendwann mal in 5 Jahren wieder billiger wird.
Doch der 7700 hat nur 4 Kerne.
Der 8700 hat 6.
Ah, jetzt können wir wieder die Defend-Action
am Bash machen.
So, wir stellen das jetzt da oben hin.
Nein!
Okay, da wollte ich nicht hin,
aber wir können auch da hochfahren mit.
Auch okay.
So, und jetzt hier gehen wir an die...
an die Gun
und stelzen alles, was hier ankommt.
Oh, oh.
Da hat er nicht mitgekommen.
Da hat er nicht mitgerechnet, der Gude.
Das ist unfair.
Das ist wirklich unfair, die Ecke hier oben.
Guck mal, wir haben als Defender...
Field... Ah, gut, das war doof.
Wir haben als Defender viel bessere Posi.
Das ist unfair.
Prime Sub gehört mir, Pog.
Poggle Field 2042.
Poggers, Poggers Field.
So rum.
Äh, au.
Oh, explodiert der einfach gerade alles.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Was?
Boris Geschütz?
Que comred, MG?
Ist das nicht der Sinn einer Verteidigungsstellung?
Doch, aber das hat ja mit der Realität nichts zu tun.
Das soll ja gut spielbar sein.
Ich finde das nicht so gut durchdacht,
weil hier rechts hast du überhaupt keine Deckung.
Das heißt, die Gegner werden meistens rechts pushen.
Äh, also quasi andere Gegner.
Andere Seite.
Captain Poggers ist weg.
Ich mach mal kurz den Motion-Sensor hier hoch.
Okay, nice.
Oh, oh, da oben kommen jetzt viele.
Monka S.
Okay, da kommen jetzt einige.
Okay, Captain Poggers, bis denn, mach's gut.
Also, ich bin noch eine Stunde on.
Falls noch einer mitspielen will,
vielleicht habe ich euch sogar schon auf Origin.
Das wäre nice.
Das Fieldersquad geht eigentlich immer besser als Dreiersquad
oder am besten Solo.
Ich frag mich eh wieder, ich frag mich ohne Scheiß,
ich frag mich, wie der Lost das aushält,
das die ganze Zeit Solo zu spielen.
Aber man jede, was ihm gefällt, ja,
aber ich verstehe es bloß nicht.
Oh, das hat geklatscht.
Das hat auch geklatscht.
Nein!
Ich wollte übrigens nicht klettern.
Dass der geklettert hat, hat mich gerade das Leben gekostet.
Ich wollte eigentlich springen um die Ecke,
aber da hat gemein...
Nein, ich kletter jetzt den Block hoch.
Ja, Ingame links, rechts, du musst, glaube ich, deinen Cache leeren,
dann geht's wieder.
Das ist ein Bug, den es mit Update 3 jetzt neu gibt.
Ein neues Bug-Feature quasi.
Ein Feature-Bug sozusagen.
Also, wenn es so was gibt wie ein Feature-Bug,
dann auf jeden Fall...
Oh, die gehen auf B.
Oh, Mann.
Dann in Battlefield 2...
Oh, da kommt der Pantsman, kommt an.
Jetzt habe ich ein Problem, wenn der Pantsman hier angefahren kommt.
Oh, Mann.
Aber der Pantsman fährt zum Glück nicht ran.
Das ist gut, dass der nicht ranfährt.
Oh, oh.
Okay.
Okay, Rush.
Ich brauche Ammo.
Alles einsammeln hier.
50 Schuss, jawohl.
So, jetzt haben wir die Seite easy defended.
Gehen wir mal rüber.
Der Berg hier oben, den können die halt echt kaum einnehmen.
Das ist ziemlich...
ziemliche Pepega-Geschichte.
Okay, der hittet gar nix, der Dude, Alter.
Keck.
Weh.
Oh, das ist ein Geschütz.
Boris.
Oh.
Game-Journalist-Modus.
Ja, so hat er echt gehittet.
Ich bin übrigens jemand, der früher übelst gelästert hat,
so nach dem Motto.
Alter, guckt euch mal an, wie scheiße irgendwie die Spieletester spielen.
Und wie können die die Games überhaupt bewerten?
Das bin ich heute deutlich entspannter, muss ich sagen.
Ich meine, ich finde es da trotzdem komisch,
warum man gerade die Leute Shooter bewerten lässt,
die Shooter nicht spielen, okay?
Aber du hast als Spielejournalist sicherlich Besseres zu tun,
als ein Game quasi auf höheres Level zu crimpen.
Am besten schon Theorie-Crafting in der Beta machen und so,
was beste Waffen sind und sonst was.
Also, ich glaube, da muss man ein bisschen Verständnis für haben,
dass die eben auch rein...
Job-bedingt nicht die krassesten Owner sein können.
Wobei es ja schon ganz gut wäre, wenn man die Leute, die ganz gut sind,
in Multiplayer-FPS zum Beispiel dann auch die Multiplayer-FPS spielen lässt.
Aber, bester Kicks auf Twitch.
Pog, whoop, arrived, Serbanjo, dankeschön für den Sub.
Sie sollten so eine Art Kund-Konzept vom Spiel, selbstverständlich.
Also, so diese ganzen Leute, die das dann schlecht bewerten, weil...
Was weiß ich?
Ähm...
Was ist denn so eine typische Too-Much-Water?
Ne, was ist denn so eine typische...
So eine typische Sache, wo ich mir manchmal denke,
Painz-Champ, Alter, wie kommen die auf so eine Idee?
Hört mir jetzt grad nix ein.
Äh, ich bekomme Experience hier nur über diese offiziellen...
Ja, genau, Cuphead ist zu schwer und so Dinger.
Ja, das ist genau sowas in der Richtung.
Ähm...
Ich bekomme XP aber nur in der offiziellen Rush-Playlist.
Leute, morgen ist Freitag, kann das sein?
Wisst ihr, dass ich am Wochenende endlich meine Steuererklärung fertig machen muss?
Also nicht die Steuererklärung, die Sachen, die ich dem Steuerberater schicke.
Ich drück mich da immer das ganze Jahr davor.
Defense aufdiscarded, das ging die letzte Male echt in die Hose.
Ich glaub, ich mach morgen ein Video zu Rush.
So, wenn ich mir das grad so überleg.
Wo sind wir denn hier gelandet?
Oh, beste Posi.
Ich glaub, hier wollte ich schon immer mal hin.
Ich spray einfach mal rein.
Ich glaub, ich mach morgen ein Video zu Rush.
Ich glaub, ich mach morgen was zu Rush.
Leute, ihr macht einen guten, richtig nicen Click-G-Bait-Titel im Kopf.
Und nicht die Standard-Ding so.
Rettet Rush Battlefield 2042.
Ich mein, ob das Spiel jetzt gerettet wird,
hab ich jetzt, glaub ich, schon 50 verschiedenen Titeln verarbeitet in irgendeiner Art und Weise.
Ihr macht eine gute Idee für einen Titel für ein Rush-Video.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was mich hier gerade...
Oh, der Pantsman!
Der Pantsman!
Rush is back.
Battlefield 2042 rusht in den Abgrund.
Das ist eine ziemlich gute Idee.
Aber man muss immer mit dem Low-Durchschnitts-IQ auf YouTube rechnen.
Das checken die Leute nicht, dass das ein Video über Rush ist.
Diese lang ersehnte Funktion ist endlich zurück.
Das ist wirklich Clickbait 2.0.
Aber ich glaub, in dem Fall zieht es mehr, dass man sagt,
Rush, weil die Leute eben Rush kennen.
Rush groß schreiben ja das eh, das eh.
Selbstverständlich schreibe ich Rush groß.
Was meint ihr denn?
Ein bisschen Clickbait-Kram kann ich ja mittlerweile auch.
Also, falls noch jemand...
Oh, oh, oh, oh, da kommt was.
Big Brain-Idee hat...
Naht nach, Alter!
Wie, die haben geplantet.
Die können nicht planten einfach so.
Ach, Banana-Planter.
Kennt das noch jemand?
Kennt noch jemand diese Montage, die der Fabian hochgeladen hat?
Lull.
Oh, das hab ich gut gemacht, oder?
Das hab ich wirklich pock gemacht.
Da müsst ihr mich mal loben.
Dass ich quasi eh gedrückt halte, ohne Moven den Typ noch gesehen hab.
Easy.
Äh, das ist ein Auto.
Alter, kann das sein, dass ich heute...
wirklich ganz gut drauf bin?
Also, sowohl Aim-Technisch geht heute echt klar.
Als auch Movement- und Play-Technisch, ne?
Ist heute wirklich in Ordnung.
Also, für 37-jährigen Boomer geht das doch.
Oh, meine.
Vielleicht liegt es auch daran...
Oh, shit.
Was war das denn?
Was hat mir denn hier ins Gesicht gepustet?
Ja, das macht auch mehr Spaß.
Das stimmt schon.
Was?
Au.
Oh, Schneiber.
Leute.
xxHD.
Jetzt kommt's.
Passt auf.
xxHD.
Oh, fuck.
Ich glaube, man macht das mit der Sniper und nicht mit der Pistole, oder?
Dank Rush nicht mehr Lost?
Ah, ist auch nicht schlecht, die Idee.
Ist mit...
Das find ich gut.
Ist mit Rush der Durchbruch gelungen?
Das muss ich mir aufschreiben.
Das find ich gut.
Gelingt...
Nee.
Gelingt mit...
Gelingt...
Moment.
Gelingt mit Rush der Durchbruch.
Das ist so ein richtiger GBA-Titel, so nach dem Motto Rush, Breakthrough, was auch immer.
Das find ich gut.
Okay, jetzt xxHD-Time, Leute.
Okay.
Fertig, xxHD.
Vielleicht liegt es auch an Halo, dass ich heute besser aimen.
Oder auch nicht.
Also...
Null.
xxHD-Schneiber ist nix für mich, Leute.
xxHD-Schneiber.
Nee, nee.
Da geht nix.
Kann ich nicht.
Bin ich nicht advanced für genug.
Wo sind denn überhaupt Gegner?
Oh, okay.
Endlich mal wieder eine ordentliche Waffe spielen.
xxHD hat nicht funktioniert.
Hast du eigentlich mehr oder weniger feste Streamzeiten?
Hab ich feste Streamzeiten, Chat?
Ich glaube, mehr random als ich kann man nicht streamen.
Einfach...
Sonntag.
Äh...
Sonntag, ähm...
sag mal so 9.30 Uhr, 10 Uhr.
Bis...
13, 14 Uhr.
Das ist eigentlich die einzig feste Streamzeit, die ich hab.
Achtung, Achtung. Wir machen jetzt Big Brain Play.
F**k, die Munni war leer.
Die Munni war leer.
NO!
Aber auch weil vorher weder die Schüsse nicht gerekt haben.
Win.
Easy.
Max rushed Battlefield von seinem Art Drive.
Nicht schlecht.
Maus M. kommt disarmbt.
Leute, ist das eigentlich der diverse Specialist oder der Hackerman?
Das habe ich jetzt immer noch nicht gecheckt.
Ich habe jetzt verschiedene Sachen gehört.
Ist das Wingsuit Grill divers oder ist der Hackerman diverse?
Nicht, dass es Sundance, okay.
Ich habe nämlich widersprüchliche Sachen gehört.
Die Meditante? Nee.
Ja, Sundance ist das Wingsuit Grill.
Okay, oh, Renewal. Mal gucken, ob es jetzt besser flutscht.
Wann kommen Elite-Skins für die Specialists?
Es gab heute ein Boris-Weihnachtsmann-Skin.
Der wurde wieder entfernt, wie es aussieht.
Zumindest habe ich den ingame nicht.
Geile Zitrone, du musst deinen Cash klären.
Nee, deinen.
Tja, frag mich nicht.
Ich habe im Vorfeld nur gelehrt, man muss irgendwie seinen Game-Cash klären.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ob das eine Origin-Geschichte ist oder ob man seinen Profil-Ordner löschen muss
und danach die Settings neu machen, keine Ahnung.
Das ist irgendwas, was später noch kommt, keine Ahnung.
Ist das hier so ein...
Jetzt ist es weg.
Das hätte auch so ein Labyrinth sein können, wo man so gucken muss, wie man da so durchkommt.
So, auf geht's.
Hovercraft, jawohl.
Bam.
Kein Hovercraft.
Leute, hier.
Dieses Ding.
Dieser Granatwerfer, der ist so dermaßen schlecht.
Wo man sich einfach nur fragen kann, wer ist auf die geile Idee gekommen,
diesen Granatwerfer einzubauen.
Okay, ich mach...
Oh nee, ich mach doch nicht die Legehände.
Und warum gibt es manchmal...
Und warum gibt es manchmal Einsteiger-Animationen und manchmal nicht?
Wir werden es nie erfahren.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, wenn der jetzt nicht stimmt,
dann raste ich aber aus.
Damit hast du nicht gerechnet, Alter, oder?
Oh oh, oh oh.
Heute geht aber gut rein.
Heute geht aber echt gut rein.
Muss man eben mal lassen, ja.
Achtung, Achtung, Big Brain Play.
Oh Mann!
Ich hasse es, wenn das Game meine Big Brain Plays nicht mitmacht.
Massive.
Das war Clip-würdig, oder?
Diese komplette Aktion war doch echt Clip-würdig, Leute.
Das müssen wir clippen.
Und er ist noch nicht fertig.
Er ist noch nicht fertig.
Es geht immer noch weiter.
Und jetzt noch ein Massive-Sniper-Kill hinten drauf.
Passt auf.
Und jetzt noch 360.
Okay.
Das hätte ja funktionieren können.
Ich bleib lieber bei meiner ordentlichen...
Was haben wir denn hier zu bieten?
Was haben wir denn da?
Taugt es?
Hallo, ich will aufhören im Spiel.
Ihh!
Ah!
Wer spielt denn sowas?
Wer...
Öhh!
Wo ist meine Waffe?
Ich will meine Waffe wieder.
Meine Waffe ist blocken.
Meine Waffe ist verbuggt.
Ich kann...
Moment!
Ach, da liegt die angeblich.
Okay, alles klar.
Das ACOG-Visier war das, ja.
Panzer nehme ich mit.
Äh...
So war das nicht gedacht, Battlefield.
Voll den Kopf gesch...
Oh, oh.
So, ein paar Motion-Sensors schmeißen.
Irgendwo da drüben ist was.
Lege Hände!
Hinter mir kommt was.
Aber vielleicht kann ich...
Nächster.
Fuck.
Oh, da werden wir abgeähmt hier.
Da werden wir abgeähmt.
Äh, Game!
Nicht rumbacken!
Oh, oh, oh!
Okay.
Irgendwann...
Irgendwann muss er ja mal sterben.
Vierzehn Leute!
Wir haben gerade vierzehn...
Vierzehn weg!
Bam, bam, bam!
Hast du schon Hourglass gespielt?
Ja.
Und ich habe voll versagt bei Hourglass.
Ach, ich stecke in der Wand.
Ich kann nicht wiederbelebt werden.
Okay.
Da machst du nix.
Schmeißer mal Motion-Sensor.
So wissen wir, was abgeht.
Okay.
So.
Hau!
Hau, au!
Hourglass ist richtig Weird.
Wirt Champ.
Oh.
Hier neben.
Wirt Champ.
Lip Wirt.
Wir sind hinterm Schild.
Da kann nix passieren.
Ja, da hat mich geteabagd.
Ich hab's gesehen.
Aber der wollte mir damit ja eigentlich nur sagen, dass es...
Ok.
Lass mich nicht schätzen.
Pass auf.
BigBrainPlay.
Alda!
Hahaha, lol.
Jetzt kriegen sie aber auf den Sack.
Five Head Blaze.
Das ist die größte Five Head Runde, die ich bisher hatte in dem Spiel.
Richtig Five Head.
Kannst du dich mal heilen?
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Du, du, du.
Oh, oh, da kommt eine Granate.
Acht Head, ja.
Oh.
Leute, ich bin zu viel am Husten.
Ihr habt recht.
Ihr habt recht, Chat.
Aber ich weiß nicht, was ich machen soll.
Zum Arzt gehen wird garantiert nichts bringen.
Weil die eigentlich nie was machen, sondern so Standarddinger von sich geben.
Außerdem, was sollen die machen gegen zu viel Husten?
Oh, es geht noch nicht los.
Charlie Mike.
Nicht mehr Oscar Mike.
Okay, das war zu viel.
Das war zu viel.
Hammer Gameplay 100.
Ja, endlich hier jetzt.
Geht mal was.
Das liegt aber auch am Squad.
Ganz ehrlich.
Das liegt auch mit am Squad.
Wenn du ordentliche Squadmates hast, dann geht es einfach.
Wir haben hier den Fatal dabei und den Captain Poggers und den Sirius Max.
Da kann nichts schief gehen.
Äh.
So war das jetzt eigentlich nicht gedacht.
Habt ihr die Hells-Anzeige gesehen über den Köpfen der Leute?
Wir shooten die Tangos, gar keine Frage.
Ich bin so ein krasser Tango-Shooter.
Fuck.
Tango hat mich geshootet von der Seite.
Tango-Shooter.
Aber zumindest, wisst ihr was das alles Gute an dem Stream von heute ist?
Ich hab zumindest für das Video morgen einfach Gameplay.
Ich nehm einfach den Stream und schneid das zusammen.
Fertig.
Easy.
Ich glaub die checken gar nicht, dass ich von hier oben anstelzen kann, oder?
Ich glaub das Ding gar nicht so klar.
Ne.
Ach, von da kommen sie.
Oh oh, Messer.
Ah, Boris.
Lass mich in Ruhe.
Win.
GG Eats.
So, also ich denk mal so 1-2 Runden bis 22 Uhr gehen noch, aber dann ist Schluss für
heute.
Ich sag's nur schon mal.
Morgen wird das 2042-Bashing-Video veröffentlicht.
Was?
Hoffentlich runtergenommen.
Ist doch ein nices Spiel.
Das Video werd ich nicht löschen.
Warum soll ich das Video jemals löschen?
Es war halt, es war halt, es war halt, es war halt, es war halt, es war halt, es war halt,
es war halt, es war halt, es war halt, es war halt, es war halt, es war halt, es war halt, es war halt,
es war halt, ich mein, es ist im Kern immer noch unfertig und undurchdacht.
Nur, weil sie mit Rush und 16 vs 16 quasi ihre eigenen Design-Entscheidungen zum Teil
wieder zurückgenommen haben, ist es jetzt besser spielbar.
Halbe Stunde noch.
Wisst ihr, was dann ist um 22 Uhr.
22 uhr
die stamm zuschauer werden es wissen
hourglass irgendjemand hatte kann auch hourglass gefragt
22 uhr ist schon spät
boomer müde bettke
achte auf die deadzone jetzt und die spawn punkte ja das ist pepega hourglass
richtig pepega oder schon bebega sozusagen
wir sind mal attacker ich glaube attackt habe ich auf hourglass
legit noch nie
die nächste section ist auch doof wo du einfach nur über die wüste laufen musst
nächste nächste base muss man einfach komplett komplett über die düne laufen ohne deckung ohne alles
richtig pepega
da unten sind sie drin guckt euch mal an
vielleicht habe ich glück und kann mich hier rüber krabbeln irgendwie
okay das dass das design hier drin ist ja wirklich der hammer
das alter du checkst ja mal gar nicht wo hier irgendwas ist
verbaut
Ach super
da ist auch da muss man erstmal durchkommen dass die restliche hälfte vom haus einfach warum ist die restliche
Warum ist die restliche
things vom haus einfach
dollars was bescheuert wir hatten die weise und die beklagte idee gekommen
Darin da rechnet sie doch nicht mit dass die hälfte vom haus auf einmal auf märz ist
Das meint es. Soja ist wirklich das richtig hängen geblieben
ihr seht mich nicht ihr könnt mich gar nicht sehen was was habt ihr habt ihr gesehen wie es
wieder durchgeflogen ist ich habe schon aufgehört zu schießen weil ich mir dachte der fällt jetzt um
das ist einfach wieder straight durchgegangen 20 kugeln oder könnte nicht sagen dass es irgendwie
an pepega lag das war genau drauf so easy wir haben es oder haben wir es doch wir haben sie
ja wohl das ist nämlich mit so die nächste base ist wirklich hart hängen geblieben wir müssen
jetzt komplett hier über die über die dünen drüber passt mal auf ja fast schon durch war schon durf
war weiter weiter rush expert nein doch kein rush expert so macht man das nämlich eigentlich man
fährt schon in durch die durch
durch die durch die durch die durch die durch die durch die durch die durch die durch die durch die
die durch die durch die durch die durch die durch die durch die durch die durch die durch die
die durch die durch die durch die durch die durch die durch die durch die durch die durch
die durch die durch die durch die durch die durch die durch die durch die durch
die durch die durch die durch die durch die durch die durch
die durch die durch die durch die durch die durch
die durch die durch die durch
die durch die durch
die durch
durch. So leicht kommen wir nie wieder
durch. Das ist wirklich schwierig, hier durchzukommen.
Normalerweise.
Monarch S. Ich steig aus.
Max, ich steig aus. Ich mach das.
Du kannst die Auto hocken bleiben.
Okay, next, next, next, next.
Machste platt?
Oh.
Rausgeschudet.
Aber vielleicht kriegen wir B. Da gehen wir an B ran.
Das schaut alles so leer aus und
keine Details. Ja, das ist ja auch
eines meiner Kritikpunkte am Map
Design hier. Dass Shanghai
2014 war das, glaube ich,
ne, wenn Battlefield rausgekommen ist.
Dass Shanghai 2014
einfach mal besser,
detailreicher und
lebendiger und schöner vor allem
ausgesehen hat, als es jetzt
sowas wie Kaleidoskop zum Beispiel
tut. Was halt schon
irgendwo ein leichtes Armutszeugnis ist,
wenn da quasi acht Jahre
oder so dazwischen liegen.
Warum hat der Dude
sich gerade nicht geheilt?
Ich hab mir doch
den Booster reingedrückt.
Oder war das schon 2013?
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum das raus...
Ja, aber die 128 Spieler, ich weiß, das ist
Kappa und Shibate, ist im Chat, aber
die 128 Spieler sind ja dafür keine Ausrede
irgendwie.
Wenn's halt nicht funktioniert mit 128,
dann lässt das halt weg. Und außerdem wüsste ich
nicht, warum das ein Problem sein sollte.
Du konntest Battlefield 3 sogar ohne Probleme
spielen mit 128 Spieler.
Alter,
die wären geklatscht.
Ach, das ist das Schild, Dude.
Easy is clap, ja.
Easy is clap.
Ich kenn die Map hier überhaupt nicht.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo hier was ist.
Außer Sand.
Sand findet man ja relativ schnell.
Ah, da drüben ist B.
Okay.
Wir grappling hooken uns jetzt einfach da rüber.
Oh, oh.
Hinter mir ist was und vor mir ist was. Das ist natürlich doof.
Achtung, ich muss mal
den Motion Sensor rüberschmeißen. Ah, perfekt.
Perfektes Aim mit dem Motion Sensor. Nein.
Unter mir.
Okay.
Hack.
Richtige Kacks.
Was machen die Dudes da hinten denn bitte schön gerade?
Irgendwie
krasse Party hinterm Schild.
Oh, das ist ein langes
Comment-Chat. Ich lese es gleich.
Ich lese es. Oh, ich stell mich in die Ecke und lese kurz.
Ähm.
Joman schreibt,
vor 10 Jahren
dachte ich, heute hätte
man die allerbesten Games,
da man ja gute Features, Beiball und
Fehler ausmerzen kann. Aber irgendwie
haben sie in jedem Game immer wieder alles erneut
über den Haufen geworfen, was manchmal gut war, manchmal schlecht.
Leute, ich sag euch, genau so,
wenn es dir vor 10 Jahren so ging, mir ging es vor 20 Jahren
so. Vor 20 Jahren,
ungelogen, ich hab's schon öfters gesagt im Stream,
ähm, ich dachte mir so zu Zeiten,
wo, keine Ahnung, wo Half-Life 1 rausgekommen ist
und sowas, dachte ich mir, meine Güte,
stell dir mal vor, 2010
oder so, 2020,
wie krass das alles sein muss.
Das ist dann quasi komplett
das Geilste vom Geilsten zusammen
und, und, wir haben nur geile Games.
Hab ich damals gedacht.
Meine Stimme hört sich anders an.
Ja, wahrscheinlich bin ich ein bisschen heiser, weil ich so viel
husten muss, keine Ahnung. Das dachte ich
damals, hab ich ja schon öfters erzählt.
Und,
ähm, es ist halt
nicht so.
Die Games sind tendenziell sogar
eher schlechter.
Ha, lull, was war das für ein Kill?
Was war denn das?
Was für ein Kill? Oh, ich hab keine.
Tango, wir shooten
die Tangos, Leute. Ich bin
der beste Tango-Shooter.
Ich, ich shoote die
Tangos. Kann man da oben drauf?
Irgendwie so?
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh.
Hat er ein Wallhack? Was ist mit dem los?
Woher weiß der, dass ich
da stell's?
Bing, bing,
bing.
Wo ist hier was?
Wo sind sie?
Aha.
Please, game. Was war das wieder?
Äh, Rush gibt's nur über Portal.
Gibt das überhaupt? Ja?
Alles voll.
Das Schöne ist ja, dass du keine Custom-Server brauchst,
sondern es gibt eine offizielle... Ach, das war's.
Das war die letzte Base. Nice. Easy win.
Ähm,
die Rush-Playlist
ist ja quasi die offizielle von
DICE.
Richtig
Legehände waren wir. Ja.
Richtig, richtig. Das Top-Legehennen-Squad.
In biologischer Haltung.
Ah,
Seilarm-Kills.
Natürlich. Also meine Pistolen-Kills
waren eindeutig am wichtigsten in der Runde.
Also das hat wirklich die ganze Runde gecarried,
als ich zwei Pistolen-Kills gemacht hab.
Also was die sich gedacht haben.
Mit der Anzeige von diesen Dingern am Ende
erschließt sich mir null.
Rush fühlt sich so gut an,
sagt der Chat. Ganz ehrlich, meine Meinung ist,
Rush fühlt sich brauchbar an,
und es kommt einem jetzt vor,
wie die Erfindung des Rats, weil der Rest
einfach so unterirdisch kacke ist.
Aber ich muss sagen, Chat, ihr seid schon
richtig, richtig next level.
Pfeifert wieder. Denn
der Titel, den Titel
finde ich gut. Also Titel,
Titel morgen von dem Video
wird wahrscheinlich wirklich sein,
gelingt mit Rush der Durchbruch.
Sind diese Sprüche cringe?
Ja, aber richtig.
Richtig
cringe.
Sind wir Attacker? Ach, Attacker hatten wir hier noch nicht.
Oh ne, ich kann mich an die Defender-Runde erinnern.
Erinnern. Einfach, Leute.
Offenes Feld.
Offenes Feld ohne irgendwas.
Ich hab ja eigentlich gesagt,
mit Battlefield 2042-Videos
ist jetzt ja mal gut, aber
es gibt jetzt halt
Sachen, wo ich gern drüber reden will
und, ich mein, die Battlefield
2042-Videos haben auch immer gute Aufrufe.
Auf der anderen Seite, ich will jetzt nicht
die Leute, die mich so das letzte Jahr über
abonniert haben, auch für die ein oder anderen
IT-Technik-Themen, gar so lange warten lassen,
bis da mal wieder was kommt.
Ich mach das ja zweigleisig. Und das war übrigens,
Leute, das war die beste Entscheidung überhaupt,
so zweigleisig das Ganze zu machen,
dass ich quasi IT-Themen
und Gaming-Shooter-Themen
mach, weil
Gaming-Shooter-Themen gibt's nicht so viele,
die mich interessieren,
meistens. Und IT-Stells
gibt's nicht so viele, die das machen
und die da auch quasi
halbwegs gehaltvoll was zu sagen können.
Das war doch nie im Leben,
ein Headshot-Game.
Okay, hier haben sie wenigstens drauf geachtet, dass man hier nicht
Headglitchen kann.
Okay, das war Pepega-Aimed gerade.
Ach, Legehände ist schon raus.
Guckt's euch mal an.
Die Legehände ist schon raus, ja.
Fuck.
Okay, ich hab nix gesagt.
Ja, da können wir schon mal rüber pushen.
Hat sich der Recoil geändert?
Das hab ich nicht gelesen.
So weit runtergescoilt
hab ich in den Patchnotes nicht, dass ich mir die
Details angeguckt hätte.
Also, die MP9 spielt sich immer noch nice.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, shit.
Okay, Legehände.
Liegehände. Liegehände mach ich jetzt gerade.
Liegehände.
Da waren grad fünf Gegner.
Einfach mal
reinsprayen.
Ich könnte ein bisschen Ammo gebrauchen.
Nein, die Ammo-Box.
Warum ist die Ammo-Box weg?
Oh, oh.
Die Legehände geht richtig ab gerade.
Guck mal hier.
Wir gehen ja da durch wie nix.
Poggers.
Poggers-Pogchamp.
Oh.
Hast du heute Spaß
an Battlefield-Chat? Ich frage euch.
Was meint ihr? Hab ich heute Spaß
an Battlefield? Es gibt zur Auswahl
Ja,
Nein und so bisschen.
Also, übertrieben geil
ist das nicht, Chat. So bisschen.
So bisschen.
Es ist nicht mehr ganz so
Es ist nicht mehr ganz so Pains-Champ
wie die ganze Zeit davor.
Und dabei, dabei.
Ich hab tatsächlich
Spaß dran, weil
es ist jetzt tatsächlich zum ersten Mal
halbwegs spielbar. Also, aber auch nur dank Rush.
Der Rest hat sich ja nix wirklich
großartig getan.
Oh, oh, der Pantsman ist da.
Nein, nein, nein.
Hol dich.
Next.
Ich kann wieder nicht springen, Leute.
Mein Sprung, meine Leertaste
ist wieder einfach kaputt.
Was ist das für eine Backscheiße immer?
Ich kann nicht springen.
Vielleicht kann ich das End klitschen, wenn ich hier drüber
ne.
Okay.
Meine Leertaste ist kaputt.
Kann ich eigentlich nur noch sterben und hoffen,
dass ich...
Warum geht die Leertaste einfach in dem Game
zwischendurch nicht?
Der Rest funktioniert ja. Warum...
Ach, jetzt geht die Leertaste... Hä?
Okay, ich hab keine Ahnung, was abgeht mit dem Spiel
wieder.
Kamen unplatzierbare Bombenspots vor.
Ja, also die Maps haben schon ganz schöne
Defender und Attacker
Bias, sagt man da ja da so schön zu.
Bling.
Aber insgesamt
ist halt einfach dadurch, dass es
16 vs. 16 ist,
schon mal um Längen
angenehmer.
Weil du hast halt nicht dieses übliche Problem...
Die Maps sacken immer noch, aber du hast halt nicht dieses übliche...
Problem, dass wenn du einen Gegner siehst,
dass dich 10 Gegner sehen.
Wenn du hier in Rush gute Plays machst,
zum Beispiel sowas hier jetzt.
Das war ja eindeutsch das beste Play aller Zeiten.
Dann killen dich die Leute dabei auch nicht.
Oh, die sind auf dem Dach.
Oh, ich hoffe, das M-Com ist nicht auf dem Dach.
Wenn das M-Com auf dem Dach ist,
dann raste ich aus.
Dann mach ich Instant Uninstall wieder.
Sollte das M-Com wirklich auf dem Dach sein,
dann dreh ich durch.
Oh, dieses Gebäude
ist so brutal leer.
Lege Henne!
Das M-Com ist schon mal nicht
auf dem Dach. Wo ist das andere?
Alter, die lassen sich
aber auch schon ordentlich wegspreien.
Wahrscheinlich wird
als nächstes die MP9 genervt oder so.
Die nerven ja
alles, was gut ist.
Ja, das Gebäude
ist leer. Es hat nichts an den Wänden
hängen. Es hat keine Einrichtung.
Es hat... Oh doch!
Guck mal. Es hat zwei Stühle.
Pock.
Wir fahren mal aufs Dach.
Nicht, dass es was bringen würde, aber
können wir mal gucken, ob das irgendwie in das Gameplay
integriert ist hier.
Äh, nee. Das geht nicht.
Ähm, mit den
Stockwerken, weil
das Game hat ja nur
Erdgeschoss und Dach in der Zwischen...
Innendrin ist ja nichts.
Nein, die M-Com sind auf dem Dach!
Die M-Com sind auf dem Dach!
Ich fass es nicht.
Die fucking M-Com
sind auf dem Dach!
Nee. Hä?
Sack.
Die M-Com sind auf dem Dach! Deiß!
Deiß!
Was soll der Scheiß, Mann?
Ich dachte übrigens, das heißt das M-Com,
deswegen bin ich wieder runtergehüpft.
Ach Gott! Warum?
Habt ihr aus Breakthrough nichts gelernt
oder was?
Ihr Kack-Noobs! Ich fass es nicht.
Wie kann man nur so
bescheuert sein?
Sie können es einfach. Sie haben es einfach drauf.
Ja.
Okay, wo war denn jetzt der Fahrstuhl hier nochmal?
Leute, ich bin verwirrt. Wo war jetzt der Fahrstuhl?
Hier oben?
Da.
Dann spawnt man nicht mehr auf dem Dach. Ja, das ist ja noch schlimmer.
Ja.
Okay.
Gegen eine DMR mit der MP9.
Just get the objective forehead.
Ja.
Die Maps haben nicht genug Platz um die M-Com's.
Oh, nice.
Nice.
Reintroppen.
Drop-Stelz.
Oh, da geht's.
Oh, da ist...
Da ist Boris geschützt.
Boris.
Okay, ich mach jetzt die Legehähne, Leute.
Fuck.
Genau, bestes Argument immer.
Wenn's dir nicht gefällt, dann kauf's doch nicht.
Genau.
Immer.
Geht immer.
Okay, jetzt clustern die sich alle oben.
Das ist natürlich Müll.
Der Typ fährt runter?
Warum fährt der runter?
Das einzige M-Com ist da oben.
Add portal full progression.
Nope.
No pass.
Oh, wo sind wir denn hier?
Wo sind wir denn hier?
Ja, wo sind wir denn hier?
Alles klar.
Auch wieder ein paar Schüsse durchgegangen.
Aber immerhin sind wir schon mal auf dem Dach.
Das ist ja meistens, meistens schon mal ganz gut.
Aber wahrscheinlich ist unser, ist unser Respawn jetzt down.
Shit.
Oh, nice, nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
Nein, ich wollte euch retzen.
Oh, oh.
Ach, der ist über mir.
Oh, pass mal auf.
Six hat.
Move.
Oh.
Haha.
Aber vom Ansatz her war das gut, oder?
Vom, vom Ansatz her kann man sich nicht beschweren.
Vom Ansatz her war das schon gut.
Das ist natürlich der Heli da gleich oben.
Oh, nee, wir haben kein, kein Dings mehr.
Shit.
Okay.
Wir müssen wieder drei Stunden laufen.
Die Innenräume sind ultra laut.
Die sind, die Maps sind halt nicht fertig.
Auf Jungs, kommt rein.
Da, da, da, da.
Gachibuzz.
Ah, der, der fährt schon da.
Die Musik.
Sly.
Und rüber hier.
Rüber.
Die haben nen fucking Heli auch noch, die Defender.
Wer ist denn auf die glorreiche Idee gekommen, die Emcoms aufs Dach zu packen und den Defender
noch ein Heli zu geben?
Warum haben die einen Heli?
Dice.
Was habt ihr euch denn dabei gedacht?
Wer hat sich gedacht, oh ich hab den Heli, ich hab den Heli.
Das ist ja nicht so einfach.
Der hat die Heli.
Warum haben die einen Heli?
Dice.
Was habt ihr euch denn dabei gedacht?
Wer hat sich gedacht?
Oh ja, das ist eine gute Idee.
Das ist auf dem Dach.
Ja, Moment, das ist auf dem Dach.
Da brauchen die einen Heli, weil wie sollen die sonst aufs Dach kommen?
Richtig.
Also das ist One Head.
One Head.
Also Two Head, Three Head ist da noch zu wenig für.
Das ist nicht vorhanden Head.
Hey, das hat ja nicht funktioniert.
Das hätte ja funktionieren können.
Null Head ist das.
No Head, genau.
Nicht No Pad, No Head.
No Pad, No Head.
Just take the objective, Leute.
Just take the objective.
Das kann doch nicht so schwer sein.
Just objective take.
So ist das Problem.
Okay, Leute, eine Runde machen wir noch.
Custom Server.
Also, es gibt ja aktuell gar keine Server.
Aber wenn,
dann mache ich irgendwas mit ein bisschen
äh, äh, äh,
Five Head, äh, Portal Rules Editor.
Kann man wieder in Portal XP fahren.
Kannst die offizielle Rush-Playlist spielen, das geht.
Warum das nicht unter All Out Warfare steht, verstehe ich übrigens auch nicht.
Ich mein,
das ist mehr Battlefield Warfare als der Rest.
Okay, spielen wir noch eine Runde Breakaway, dann ist es gut.
Haben die jetzt eigentlich wirklich
den Boris- und, äh, Webster-Skin entfernt, oder sehe ich's bloß nicht?
Zwei Helis und M-Com aufm Dach.
Ja, äh, äh, äh, Gag, weh.
Okay, Game.
Laden, please.
Ach, die Skins sollten nicht sichtbar sein.
Ah.
Wo sehe ich denn die Weekly-Aufgaben?
Das gucken wir uns gleich mal an, Leute.
Wo man das sieht.
Wie alt ist Max eigentlich?
Viel zu alt.
Ich bin 77.
Ich kann wieder nicht aussteigen, Mann.
Warum ist das so ver...
Au!
Warum ist das so verbuggt?
Ach, die Weeklys sind noch gar nicht drin, ne?
Okay, wir überrennen die grad richtig.
Habe ich doch noch zwei Runden?
Keine Ahnung.
Oh, Serious Max hat Bugs beim Join.
Blum.
Ich retz dich.
Massive Rettstells.
Ah!
Oh.
Knapp, knapp.
Wenn der Kram hier alles ein bisschen schneller gehen würde und man könnte ordentlich moven.
Stellt euch mal vor, man könnte seinen Defi aufladen und dann hingehen, bzzt, reviven und wieder zurück.
Es soll ja schon mal Spiele gegeben haben, da ging sowas.
Boah, da unten sind 50 Milliarden Gegner.
Okay, da ist wirklich viel los.
Und hier kommt bestimmt gleich irgendwas rauf.
Und ich werde nicht in die richtige Richtung gucken.
Ich sag's euch.
Weiß schon, ich guck bestimmt in die falsche Richtung, klar.
Okay.
Ja, klar, Boris.
Alles klar, Boris.
Das hast du überlebt.
Pass auf, der kommt jetzt von hinten und will mich Gachi-busten.
Gibt's aber nix!
Wenn hier einer Gachi bust, dann ich.
Okay.
Oder auch nicht.
Dachte eigentlich mit ner MP9 im Nahkampf reinbreddern.
Overwatch Beta-Zeit.
Ja, Overwatch Beta war das Beste.
Overwatch Beta war Massive POG.
Aber richtig POG.
Ich finde fast in der Beta hat Overwatch am meisten Spaß gemacht.
Kommt rein.
Auf.
Move.
Ne.
Wow!
50 Milliarden Gegner.
Das war ein Konsolenspieler, wahrscheinlich.
Der Typ hinter mir, meinst du?
Ja, wahrscheinlich war es ein Konsolenspieler.
Oder der, der mich auto-aimt hat.
Max-MW2-Gameplay.
Da warst du aber richtig früh, weil so richtig, so richtig Abos bekommen habe ich ja erst mit Black Ops.
Also wer MW2 am Start war, der war wirklich sehr früh an, früh dabei.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, nein.
Angel did it again.
Der war wirklich richtig früh dabei mit MW2.
Alter, was ist das hier?
Ayabina, Ayabina.
Ne, das war Black Ops 2, oder?
Warte mal, Leute.
War das, war das Black Ops 2 oder MW2?
Oh, jetzt geht's ab.
Zombie-Fan, danke schön für die fünf gegifteten Subs.
Wer hat denn hier gedodged?
Die Hälfte des Chats hat gedodged.
PrimeSky hat was bekommen. Epic Lunch.
Varyon, Frexor, Dosenbier.
Huge.
Ne, ne, ne, BO1 war BO2.
Ayabina, Ayabina. Das war BO2.
MW2 war täglich gut.
MW2 war Tango-Sucker.
Huge-Schmäle-Kill.
Habt ihr eigentlich gesehen, wie kacke die Animation ist?
Die ist doch immer richtig reudig, oder?
Jetzt mal ehrlich.
Mann! Kugeln, geht mal rein.
Der Ultra-Skiller.
Ja, bester.
Kaum ist der Serious Max weg, läuft's nicht.
Läuft's nicht.
Wisst ihr?
Das Cute Squad muss komplett zahlen, sonst wird das nix.
Du hast ein Video mit Commander Krieger gemacht.
Ich hab mit relativ vielen damals ein Video gemacht.
Was für mich hart anstrengend war, weil ich nicht gerne mit anderen Leuten rede.
Saugt man gar nicht, aber...
Ist so.
Boah, ey.
Okay, wir müssen das anders machen. So funktioniert das nicht.
So funktioniert das nicht.
Guckt euch das mal an hier.
Vier, vier.
Das Morgendämmerer Squad ist nur Achter anstatt Erster.
Das geht nicht.
Welfield jetzt gefixt.
Das einzige Gute ist, 16 vs 16 ist nicht mehr so Clusterfuck.
Und deswegen halbwegs spielbar.
Okay, vielleicht können wir krasse Flankerino machen.
Klautern wir den Kill.
Au.
Ist der grad bereckt?
Okay.
Yolo, Yolo, Yolo, Yolo.
Alter, was ist denn hier los?
Du machst irgendwie Flank hektion und das ist ja fast schon wie 64-64.
Obwohl es nur 16-16 ist.
Wie haben Sie es gelegt, Legehängtchen?
Nice! Der Fätel hat es gelegt.
Jetzt müssen wir nur noch Defenden.
Was relativ einfach geht,
Weil ich das Gefühl habe,
Ohhhh.
Ich sage es noch, ich sage es noch.
Normalerweise finde ich,
ist das Defenden 1facher.
spilled
das M-Com-Defend-Vendor mal gelasht hast.
Na mal!
Ist jetzt wieder ESL-Lobby angesagt
zwischendurch.
Zum Glück kam er ein Stückchen weg.
Die lasern gut rein hier wieder.
Ich will mal kurz aufs Dach gucken.
Das Auto ist am Start.
Ernsthaft jetzt. Ernsthaft, ja.
Der hat nur drauf gewartet,
dass da einer um die Ecke kommt,
um dann mit seinem
komischen
RPG-Ding reinzuhauen.
Aber es gibt keinen
Sensorkranaten-Nerf.
Leider, ich finde die Dinger auch
viel zu OP.
Ehrlich gesagt.
Du denkst, dass ich den nicht gesehen habe, oder?
Okay, also
das ist echt das Camper-Zelt überhaupt.
Okay, was heißt Camper? Das sind Defender.
Was sollen sie machen, ja?
Was sollen sie machen?
Okay, Leute.
Richtig nicer Stream heute.
Endlich hat das Game einen Modus.
Den man spielen kann, ohne permanent
übertrieben krass abzuregen.
Die Sache ist halt die,
im Kern
sind die Probleme,
vor allem die Maps, immer noch offensichtlich und da.
Und ich sag euch, wie es ist.
Rush wird auch, wenn es in der Form bleibt,
langweilig werden
nach 1-2 Wochen.
Moment, was? Rush wird es nur eine Woche geben?
Wie jetzt? Wie?
Also, wenn die wirklich Rush rausnehmen,
dann sind sie noch dümmer, als ich, als ich...
Ist es limited?
Sind die, sind die von allen guten Geistern verlassen, oder was?
Ernsthaft?
Die einzige Kacke, die du in diesem Spiel
erträglich spielen kannst,
ist limited, oder was?
Meine Güte, äh.
Das kann, das sollte sich den Ernst...
hängen geblieben.
Ich sag jetzt, richtig hängen geblieben.
Wenn das echt so ist...
BF2...
Rush limited time.
Ups.
Nicht, ich hab Battlefield 3 eingegeben,
also Battlefield 2042.
Ja, ja.
Nee, das, das...
Die hätten sich die Leute schon aufgeregt drüber,
wenn das der Fall wäre.
Das ist bestimmt she baited.
Der Chat hat bestimmt she baited.
Ist bestimmt doch nicht limited.
Geh nochmal zurück.
Oder meinst du hier die Patchnodes?
Nee.
Erstes Google-Ergebnis.
Hä? Nee.
Okay, Leute, keine Ahnung.
Ähm, ich geh jetzt
Badge, wir sehen uns.
Guck mal ganz schnell,
ob ich noch irgendjemanden hosten kann.
Mal ein Kleines, der das, der das braucht.
Alles klar, nö.
Okay, Leute, wir sehen uns, bis denn.
See you.
Bis, bis morgen wahrscheinlich, gucken wir mal.
Bis denn, macht's gut.
Tschüss.